[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god we're back happy new year
ladies and gentlemen welcome to 2022
this is fat man beyond i'm kevin smith i
am mark bernard hey
oh we're back ladies and gentlemen just
when you thought it was all over just
one last time we spoke we were like
we'll see you next year it's [ __ ]
this year and it's happening already man
uh we got so much to talk about uh
including book of boba but before we
even dive into that we got him for a few
minutes so we're going to talk to him
right up front he's a busy man and he's
working as we speak uh welcome
to fat man beyond a guy who shot
some of the last season's mandalorian
and a lot of uh boba fett as as you're
gonna see all season long but definitely
we saw his name all across season one uh
name that's very near and dear to my
heart because he shot my first movie as
well
from clerks to boba fett ladies and
gentlemen give it up for baby dave klein
i don't think people call me that
anymore come on man
i'm trying to brand you that's t-shirts
man that's marketing
um dave uh you have been uh deep being
now for nearly 30 years a
cinematographer dave and i met in film
school at vancouver the vancouver film
school um dave
shot clerks which
clerks is a movie that everyone loves
from a black and white movie
that looks like it was shot through a
glass of milk with no money whatsoever
to the very first season uh very first
episode that you just watched of boba
fett along the way he's done true blood
he's done uh uh was the one with the
lady who's like my mind homeland
homeland the show i absolutely love he's
got the worst description of that show
ever
he got it he knew it right away
dave's uh shot deadwood true calling
thank god you knew what it was
um but medium
talk about medium yeah he shot a whole
bunch man now he's shooting in the world
of star wars what is it like dude to
deal in that world how many things here
i'm going to start with the question
that i texted dave after i watched boba
fett episode one
i said
how did the banthas work
like
you have
do you have elephants wearing outfits
how did that work dave how did the
banthas work and i was like no
my man
we don't have elephants
we have we have one banta that's filled
with about four puppeteers
and another four people on a little
remote controls and the other the other
three or four or five are cg and it's on
a motion base and it does this and it
goes across the back lot and we shoot it
and motion based is what it's like a
dolly
well it's on track and it's motorized
but a motion base can be programmed to
animation
so you animate it in the previz to do
you know to do its little walk and then
they program that into the motion base
and it does its little walk
so it's not so in the first star wars if
i remember correctly i think like they
did use animals as like a bantha or
something that's right you guys built a
gigantic
puppet one of these exists somewhere in
the world right correct
yes
that is to do birthday parties yeah i
know oh my god can we read that's the
first question
this is but this to me is like this is
the embracing of true star wars or at
least the blending of two true star wars
um when when george lucas was doing the
original trilogy or the prequel trilogy
you know it was a lot of like i'm gonna
make all the animals and everything in
cg and then since they've started the
you know the disney plus shows and and
jj stuff it's been tactile let's make
aliens that are tactile
i'm telling you that bantha thing
captured my imagination and it makes me
so happy to know that they built one
they didn't have to they could have just
cg them all in why build one at all
you know our our methodology has always
been and look i started late i started
in uh season two of um mando as the
second unit cinematographer and then i i
ended up shooting episode six with
robert um and that's when i started
that's when i you know
came to this galaxy basically and
learned that
our methodology
always goes back to how would george
have done it in 77
and that's where we start of course you
know he didn't have motion bases and
things like that so we cheat a little
bit obviously but he also didn't have
vfx like we do so we we cheat a lot
actually but it always needs to start
with that in mind and
um even when we're doing visual effects
work and cg work it starts with that you
know it has to feel real it has to feel
like you know you can't just put the
camera anywhere you got to put it where
he could have put it in 77 you have to
move it like he would have moved it in
77 so that's why it's it's puppets it's
practical [ __ ] everywhere you know what
i mean it's
um every we we always try and do it real
and until it becomes you know
financially
ridiculous
basically so you know banta just four
guys in a banta amazing you you um
you've been shooting the show the show
historically from season one on
the hype around the show was they shoot
on the volume man they got that volume
wall and that's makes all the difference
and for those that don't follow most
people watch this show know the volume
is uh just we got the dp right here
describe what the volume is dave the
volume is uh it's a it's an led volume
so it's led walls and a ceiling
um it's about
60 feet wide it's about 100 feet long
it's an oval the first season it was
round and the problem with that was that
they had to re-record all the dialogue
because if you're in a round building it
just echoes like crazy so season two it
became an oval and you know if you stand
at a certain certain you know if you're
dead center
it echoes like crazy but otherwise it's
it's pretty you know
you can record sound in there and it
works um but it's it's an oval it's all
it's led screens led ceiling
and you know there are a lot of rules in
there it's tough to you can't do day
exterior
if you need
you know direct sunlight it's just it's
impossible because it's it sounds like
it's big 60 by 100 but it gets small
really quick
so well for example like episode one of
bulba you guys are outdoors a lot
there's a lot of
as i was watching that i was like well
that ain't the volume they had to be in
the real world yeah if if you see
something that's out uh in the open
desert with direct sun we're outside
what uh what the um in what about when
you did the episode in mandalorian with
boba so it's was that six it was six was
there much buying there's a lot of
outdoor work in that as well that was
the first time uh season two episode six
was the first time the men you know the
show the mandalorian had left manhattan
beach
and we went to we went to simi valley
for a week so you were just on location
for the entire episode no just for a
week just for a week yeah um what is it
what are the challenges
of shooting a star wars like we all
think about the dream like oh my god you
get to see the you can see grosgu you
get to see luke skywalker you get to see
this what are the challenges of shooting
a legendary space epic you know as it
moves forward uh both the psychological
challenges and just the physical
challenges of like how do you like
something like this
uh the biggest challenge is is getting
jaded towards star wars
i mean
but it hasn't happened yet i've been
here for two years i guess
right i guess one day if you're just
like i don't believe this ever happened
a long time ago in any galaxy
well i gotta tell you the first time i
was ever in a hallway you know a star
destroyer hallway shooting stormtroopers
you know i was i was 12 years old again
you know and i and i told the story on
the set because i i actually had that
boba fett special edition
you know the one that is probably worth
twenty thousand dollars now
i i had that one i sent the general
mills box tops in with a check for three
dollars and 35 cents or whatever it was
and they promised that it was gonna have
the rocket that shoots out the back
right and it shows up and it shows up in
that [ __ ] rockets glued in
right
whatever i blew it all to hell while i
was making a 16 millimeter stop
animation you know film
uh and my dad was my special effects guy
because he used to help me
he wasn't in the business he was a
doctor but he used to help me with my
little model rockets right and one day i
go into him and i say hey dad
if i cut the end off of this this rocket
engine and then ignite it will it just
explode
and he said
come again
maybe 12 year old dave you need some
help so he helped me start making these
little 16 millimeter films with the
bolex and and i blew the hell out of
that special edition boba fett so it's
it's fitting that i'm here and every day
i kept answering your question it's it
it makes me 12 again it absolutely makes
me 12 again i'm like that's a [ __ ]
storm trooper right there
you know when you guys when you guys are
sitting down to start a season you know
is there a is there like a visual diet
that you all go on like we're going to
watch a lot of curacao we're going to
watch a lot of leone we're going to
watch a lot of david lean like what is
what were what was part of the sampler
platter of visual references you guys
were drawing from it's it's across the
board really and it depends on yeah uh
the the directors you're working with
like like uh
i have to remember what my nda says yes
very careful kids because dave is
you know dave has worked on things and
dave would like to continue to working
on things so he's going to be very
careful about what he says
do you think mickey mouse is is watching
this podcast right now oh yeah
you tell me
um
so it depends on the director for
example like uh when i started working
with robert we
initially you know we had that big fight
episode with boba fett and all the
stormtroopers and robert roberts
hilarious he's a kind of a you know
nerdy genius as well
he actually shot his own little priebus
with
star wars action figures you know and
and so he did his own little animatic
and we actually watched a lot of his
movies because he knew he had these
little things he references from his own
pictures that he wanted to put into
uh uh that episode and so we watched a
lot of that and you know i've worked
with dave filoni and when you're working
with felony it's it's a lot of kurosawa
you know and it's it's a lot of samurai
stuff and and so
but it always starts with doug chang i
gotta say it always starts with doug
chang and his concept art and that's
where i always try to get
when i'm trying to figure out how to
light a set you know when i'm trying to
figure out you know to get some some
idea of where the lighting should come
from and and how to do it
uh for a new set or something i go to
doug's concept art because it's it's
exquisite you know what i mean it's if i
could ever light us out the way that he
you know paint something and draw
something then
i'd be a happy man i don't think i'll
ever get there but that's always where i
start that's the visual language that i
start with is that the concept art we
see during the credits at the end of the
show 100 such a good idea for them to
roll that man like a good use of it
somebody spent their time doing it and
and previously only like 10 people see
it now it's a world where he like put it
on the credits it's very very dope the
um so for every scene that you shoot
or at least like every for every scene
you're gonna go is there one of those at
least for
the scene like so that you know
what everything's looking like are those
your
storyboards for lack of a better
description
oh no no no no there are a lot of
storyboards there well there are there
aren't storyboards there's a full
previews there's a full animatic
of every episode uh sometimes there's
before you shoot it there's a full
animatic yeah wow
yeah that's that's i gotta say that's
one the way that the the volume works
you have to know what you're doing ahead
of time
you know because you're
um
i'm getting yelled at to come back set
but um
uh you have to know you know your
backgrounds we've been lighting these
backgrounds and in vr you know i i spent
i spent so much time in vr goggles
lighting the the the backgrounds you
know and then it's like a four-month
process for when we start you know
lighting the vr backgrounds until we can
actually look at them on the walls
um
wow
yeah it's it's it's a big deal
um sorry i lost my shirt down because
i just got six i just got 16 text
messages
um anyway you got any last last thing
and it was the last thing and i'll i'll
come back another time i hope absolutely
uh the last thing is uh uh episodes one
and two already up a boba fett you uh
i'm not saying you've
dp'd any of the others but if you did
i i think the imdb might the imdb might
tell you that i
shot three five six and seven
what are your favorite episodes of this
run what what are the ones we should be
looking forward to
five six and seven
the end the end is cool
um go shoot your show all right before
we uh we i went and made clerks through
this summer there was a red hot minute
where dave was uh
caught between a rock and a hard place
between shooting clerks three and
shooting star wars uh shooting a star
wars type thing and i said dave there is
no rock and there is no hard place
clarks is the past star wars is the
future embrace the future and you made
the star wars vision but you were missed
but you made the right decision
particularly when i sat there and
watched episode one on my big ass screen
tv and even my wife who watched it with
me jennifer was like my god it's
gorgeous i was like oh that's baby dave
right there thank you man but you know
what i wouldn't be anywhere in this
business
without you sir stop it i'm not kidding
i'm not kidding stop it you rock
go tell everyone i said hello
all right
love you guys sir talk to you guys later
thanks for having me on
thanks for being here no longer a
baby
man dave kline
look at that
he's he's working with me you and me
we're like we're working we're not
working he's really working um
he can't say because he does have like a
series of ndas of course that they make
them sign and you know one has to be
very careful let's he slip with any
particular detail
uh but i'll say what he can't he was
there
he was working on on the on the show
yeah that's his production office like
he walks out of there he's in the volume
if he would have turned his his camera
down you would have seen like the
monitor in his office where they were
getting ready for the next setup and
stuff like that like he's actually
working so it was very cool of dave to
take the moment
uh to talk i blew him up man when i saw
boba was like oh my god come on and talk
about it stuff but i i did
i did ha i had to ask about the panthers
like i felt so stupid like because my
wife asked me and i was like i
i don't know
because they look so [ __ ] real and i
know you know i think i got an eye for
cg but the way they moved and
programming them for movement i guess
kind of makes sense because they did
have this lumber and all they do is like
they got the one and then they just
duplicate it from cg
you know it all comes down to ultimately
at the end of the day
three toddlers in an overcoat
yeah
yeah no doubt
that banff that could probably go get
into a pornographic movie
same way
exactly
when kids welcome back
uh fat man beyond and look bath bands
here everybody give it up for banff man
uh right before you jumped on the call
and dave jumped on
he his background was full of things
where i was like this is gonna get
broadcast should you turn your camera
around and he was like
oh yeah i should oh [ __ ] yeah yeah good
looking out good looking out man um it's
it's a
it's a good gig for him nobody wants him
to lose that gig particularly over this
crap could you imagine you're shooting
star wars things you're working with
fabs and felony and
and then one day you get the call in the
office you're like yeah man the
yeah
there's the tarp on the floor
they call up on the big screen like were
you on this podcast oh no
okay
pescium right there oh no before it gets
thinking
um yeah i'm so glad that he was able to
jump on and
say hello man it's you know what a
glow-up [ __ ] bro like
don't go from shooting kevin smith's
[ __ ] to shooting [ __ ] star wars
that's a glow-up man that's very cool
uh how are you captain how was your uh
holidays
um
awful i think is probably the most
specific uh succinct way to put it the
[ __ ] what happened
well i uh
it was it began it began on december
18th
when i flew back to new york with my son
to go and celebrate my mother's 80th
birthday
um your mom who's been on the show my
mom has been on the show who came to the
scum and villainy who hung out was
aghast at the language we use on a
regular basis
um
yeah so she turned 80 as we went back to
fetch her as as and give her roses as it
should do and at some point in our new
york trip my son caught covet
and he probably caught the omicron
so we got back to l.a and again a tickle
in his throat
got tested
came back positive so and he quarantined
for eight or nine days
until the communicability until the
contagion the contagious phase passed
but that was christmas like we we pushed
christmas until after new year's so that
he could recover and then when he
recovered my wife caught it because
of course she did and then when she
caught it my daughter caught it which
was the scary part because she's she's
vaccinated but she's got the jnj she's
got no booster
she's the world's worst patient in the
world for anything medical
and so
you know just all right here we have
this autistic kid who's now got [ __ ]
covet
this should be great
and then did you dodge the bullet
i dodged it up until what feels like
yesterday
you know i've been testing negative i've
been testing negative the whole time but
then i got like the tickle in my throat
and then yesterday like i started to get
sneezy and my nose start to run and i'm
like is this a cold or is this [ __ ]
the copic and when i get home tonight
i'll take an home test and then if that
comes up positive then i'll go take a
pcr test
but like i don't feel awesome
but it's
it it's a wonder that i hadn't caught it
until now if this is in fact what it is
it could also just be the [ __ ] flu
that's the thing right like i mean i
guess
in order to find out you have to take an
expensive test um what
uh first i'm processing all the
information what was it like for the
family that everyone's vaccinated and
are they all boosted no not all booze um
my wife and i are boosted my son got
boosted the day we got back from new
york so like the day he got his positive
test was the same day that he got the
booster
which you know ultimately helped i guess
ameliorate the worst of it because as
bad as it got it was a fever and chills
and headaches and some body eggs but no
respiratory issues nobody was short of
breath nobody had anything that that
felt like we were going to think about
hospitalization
it was it was as if you just got hit
with the worst cold you'd ever got
um
so so yeah i mean now spirits are good
spirits are high everybody's kind of on
the mend but it was [ __ ] dodgy and it
was also
you know the the the mixture of emotions
between like sadness
and and guilt
and anger
and all of it it's like we were as
careful as people got
you know like we we barely ate outdoors
in i mean at restaurants anywhere and it
was always outdoors when we did
always maxed we got facts we did all the
things you know but
but it happened anyway
so it was it was a tumultuous period
when the rest of the world is jubilant
and you're just sitting in your house
like watching it's like it's
merry christmas charlie brown through
gritted
everyone's everyone okay now except for
you everyone's okay except for me i've
got the i'm bringing up the caboose of
not feeling great but you don't know if
you have it yet but you probably you
suspect that you do
it would make all the sense in the world
like and i don't understand how i didn't
get it before
you know because i my son and i did
everything together when we were in new
york for like three or four days and so
like we were both as exposed as the
other was so i was like why don't i have
it why didn't i get it but what a beer
it is it's got to be a commercial for
for the vaccine the fact that you wear
the poster and booster that you were
able to like dodge it and then when it
came in
you know that it's not like it's it
didn't send anybody to the hospital
no yeah thank goodness
um so yeah that that blue that blue i'm
so sorry to hear that man that's a
bummer they say you know that
lord knows i've even hesitant to talk
about it because i'm sure [ __ ] chad
is blown up with like
all sorts of opinions but
uh
you know they say that
this version of it is so transmissible
chances are we're all gonna get crime
yeah you know
this is the side effect of you know this
is now the beginning of just the way
it's going to be which is there's going
to be a covet season in the same way
there's a flu season because
if enough people don't get vaccinated we
will never get hurt immunity and there
will always be variants and they will
come and they will surge because humans
will do what humans do which is i want
to go and see my family in the holidays
i want to go and be with people in the
summer i want to go on vacation and so
we'll just get these seasonal spikes
that will be awful for a while and then
they'll change every year so hopefully
the new booster will get boosted every
year the same way you get a flu shot
every year
um it didn't have to be this way
it absolutely did not have to be this
way but this is the way it is i was
supposed to be in uh new orleans
uh today
for the uh fan expo
but uh the doctor was just like
[Music]
mr high risk heart attack victim which
i often don't think about
uh probably to my detriment like it's
now been almost four years since i had a
heart attack and
you know i i kind of processed it and
went through it all very quickly and and
kind of got right back to work and stuff
like that
and in moments like this when they're
like oh no
you're lame
and debilitated
i'm like i i mean look i always knew i
was lame people been telling me that
since [ __ ] grade school but
debilitated
so yeah it's
you know it's it's a bummer [ __ ] it's a
bummer um yeah but i've been dodging it
so far
it's good for you man because i've been
out there like honestly i was on b-reels
podcast like a couple weeks ago
and i you know i i assumed i just i
didn't even think to ask like
everybody's vaccinated right we were
doing a podcast where everybody was like
hot boxing
and you know i drove home going like
if i don't have omicron homicron
i i then from that
right
then i'm
yeah i mean heavens and thank knock wood
so far no but i you know i'm not like
one of those people i don't believe in
it i [ __ ] believe it i'm scared of it
and dodging it like crazy stuff and uh
it changed my plans this weekend and
this month in general so
fingers crossed this [ __ ] goes away man
i mean just when we were getting i mean
to put it back on
point just when we're getting to a place
where like [ __ ] spider-man can make a
billion dollars something that hasn't
happened since 2019. i know that's not
like we should all be pulling for this
people so that corporations can make
billions of dollars
but you know as a movie fan as a movie
you know a fan of marvel movies in
general
you know seeing them hit that milestone
easily fairly [ __ ] quickly you know
like right on the world's back to normal
there was a sense of [ __ ] normalcy
because of spider-man no way home making
as much money as it did everybody see it
in the theater but now
you know
things yeah it found the window it found
like the last time you could probably do
that apparently that window was was
spider-man no way home and that's when
the crown was like that was it
they were coming
you know and now they're canceling like
their grammys are being postponed and
the sunday dance is virtual again
and you know golden globes well nobody
gave a [ __ ] but
those were boycotted by a bunch of
people and stuff
for different reasons all together
but yeah everything's starting to shut
down again i had a i wouldn't say a full
uh january but i had things in january
that took place outside of this house
but
right now i'm gonna be in this little
box for most of january
yeah i don't know when we get back to
the cantina but it's probably not going
to be for a bit no we have to be doing
this for a minute kids which
which allows us to do crap like this
look at what sideshow
sent as a christmas gift
wow
[ __ ] aztec batman bro
that's awesome
how [ __ ] dope is that man
that was very cool i don't know if they
sell them or not but i put it on my
shelf i [ __ ] love it
um
this is what we sold for christmas well
i didn't but inside editions did you
know we got that kevin smith book
that
kevin the secret stash
inside editions made a fat ass
binder version
comes with like not just that book but
then it comes with this secondary book
and the book is glorious man uh if you
like kevin smith even if you're remotely
interested in kevin smith it seemed to
be the christmas gift that on my twitter
feed everyone was getting each other
this comes in the special edition it's a
fake version of the escudenoverse bible
that atlanta's held at the end of jane's
on bob strickback so it's signed and
numbered but it comes with
nate
our very own nate gonzalez's book
smartest with all of our show artwork
but comes this cool ass puzzle
uh from the front cover art of the book
man it's glorious they just sent me one
it's [ __ ] fantastic um very like
i like that they sold ultimately what is
a stash book for weed
and was like
but there's a puzzle okay it's a puzzle
case it's not anything else than that
once you make the puzzle you put your
weed in that box man that's brilliance
uh but it's a gorgeous gorgeous book and
i sent i know that book uh works because
i sent it to my mother and she called me
up crying she was like oh tiger you've
done so many things so
if you want a puff that'll make you say
oh tiger you've done so many things
kevin smith's secret stash you can get
one on amazon or you can get that fat
ass edition on insight
uh editions did you get anything cool
for christmas other than [ __ ] covert
um
uh not really because my wife is is
running up against the uh the problem
that i'm sure
lots of longtime wives have which is
i've been married to this [ __ ]
for like 20 years
anything i could have gotten him i have
gotten him and also he does well enough
in the world that if he really wants a
thing he just goes out and buys a thing
i have the same situation
so much
this year my wife was like look
you're impossible what do you want i was
like i i really don't want anything
whatever i want i just go kind of get
when i want it i was like but
we're starting to show the movie here at
the house you know screenings upstairs
and um i was like but you know the tv
the sound system and the tv
somebody the other day commented was
like kind of
weak so i don't know maybe a tv with a
better
you know thing and so
she
reached out to jay and jay was like i
know what to get and
i have a very [ __ ] modern looking
television upstairs man i haven't bought
a tv in [ __ ] over 10 years we still
have that gigantic tv in my bedroom the
panasonic that still works
but um so panasonic is out of business
as a company but you're like i still got
my panasonic are they out of business as
a company
well i i that is the only i have not
heard the word panasonic
in what feels like 10 or 15 years wow
i'm sure the chat will correct me if i'm
wrong because i'm sure that i am but if
he takes a look and keeps on ticking it
never even took a look and it's still
going but when it dies eventually this
was for those who are like what
years ago ed jando is a lovely gentleman
who worked at panasonic
uh gave me this tv that they were going
to get rid of
this gigantic 103-inch monitor that they
use
tall as a human being
they used for like the olympics and he's
like it has no speaker system on you'll
have to buy speakers i was like [ __ ]
i'll buy the speakers
so i've had this [ __ ] in my room
just
this this many feet from the bed
for like the last decade and
you know
one day it's bound to go because we
watch the [ __ ] out of it and [ __ ] but
when it goes like i don't know how we're
gonna get out because it was two tons
getting it in was like madness we might
just
turn it into a bed or some sort of [ __ ]
even if it's like not working but that's
when you move
that's it leave that tv and abandon the
bucket
so we hadn't bought a tv and we didn't
even buy that tv so i bought a tv and i
can't tell you how [ __ ] long
so she bought me a tv from for for
christmas and you know i was like
yeah it was more practical because it
was like now i could show people the
movie without
worrying about the sound and stuff you
know the gift that i did get that was
lovely was um my wife bought me a
director's chair
awesome gift you put your name on it she
put my name on it mark bernardin
director
bro what are you talking about she's
like we've been married 20 years she
don't want to get me that's the
perfection of a gift it was the perfect
gift it was the perfect gift classy
that's so close
but every every year it's a struggle for
both parties concerned well this year
she made out like a bandit man she's
like who's the director i got theme gift
she could have gotten you a [ __ ]
megaphone
[Laughter]
um we have a sponsor kids uh somebody's
always helping us pay our bills the
reason we get to talk to you is because
somebody
uh jumps on board who is our sponsor uh
first half of the show mr mark bernardin
um the first half of the show we have a
new sponsor first time sponsor for the
fat man beyond program is that right is
it is it's called imme the world's first
low carb high protein in 100 high
protein high protein and 100 plant-based
instant ramen each serving the mimi has
21 grams of protein 19 grams of fiber
and only
six grams of net carbs
the [ __ ] is this serious we're fine
we're doing a commercial for something i
could eat
absolutely oh i'm sorry
emmy
emmy i am i
um
holy crap man let's go through this list
low carb
only six grams of net carbs per serving
high protein 21 protein
100 percent plant-based good for
digestive health lower in sodium so
they'll have to add your own salt
convenient emmy is super easy to prepare
in the microwave or stovetop and you
could have a bowl ready in seven minutes
delicious and comforting crafted
plant-based flavors man spicy beef ramen
tom yum shrimp ramen black garlic
chicken ramen i am down for the beef and
the chicken man i've never been a shrimp
person
high quality ingredients we use high
quality ingredients for the noodle and
soup base with no natural conservatives
but how is it different
it's 85 percent lower net carbs than
other ramens well that helps man cause
those other ramens are pretty much all
carbs
uh it contains three times more protein
four times more fiber more traditional
instant ramen brands use meat based
ingredients and unhealthy preservatives
in their soup bases emmy is a 100
plant-based product that uses high
quality ingredients man um here's the
thing even if you're like i ain't vegan
i like to eat all the soups and with the
meats and stuff you can still enjoy this
man tasty that's the idea and healthy
uh
where where should we send them to pick
this up i'm gonna go buy it now as you
say it
we're gonna send them to emmy meets
i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s
emmyeats.com fat man
and use the code fatman at checkout for
five dollars off your order that's amy
eats i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s
dot com fat man to get five dollars off
a variety pack today i am like i'm on
the page man it says welcome kevin smith
fans why hello i'm buying this [ __ ] dude
like the first time during the show that
i'm like i'm using the show to buy
something
one-time purchase oh no i don't think so
six packs
that's for lesser people 12.
variety chop well i don't need the
shrimp so i'm just going to hit this bad
boy here do it they also offer a 100
percent happiness guarantee so you can
try any risk free and decide for
yourself if amy is worth it and if
you're not happy with your emmy they
will offer you a full refund within 30
days of purchase
i am all over this oh my god man go to
emmy meets a-i-m-m-i-e-a-t-s
dot com slash fat man
um or uh and you'll do they have to say
anything or no
use
batman
all one word to check out maybe i'm
i'm in oh my god man
any eats.com
emmy's finally putting some ramen back
in my mouth it's been years
since i've had ramen being a plant-based
individual plant-based timmy is gonna
close the gap i can't wait to eat it i
literally just ordered it as well as
we're doing the show uh like be like kev
go to emmy.commyeats.com
fat man uh we thank the good folks at
emmy
for sponsoring the first half of this
episode of fat man beyond uh i
particularly as a vegan thank them
that's one more thing to have the
[ __ ] diet yeah kick ass
um all right
i've been good man like i was uh
i've been writing
uh most of the holiday um and eating oh
my god i gorged
i lost uh a close uh friend canine
friend friend [ __ ] family member
between the last time we did this and
and now marty mad martign uh our rescue
dog
uh we don't even know how old she was
man but she was plenty old
um
made it uh right to
a couple days after
christmas and then uh
you know it was she was she had tumors
inside and she was eating three bowls of
like meat like steak chicken
you know real not just dog food [ __ ] a
day and very little was coming out of
her so and her stomach kept getting
bigger bigger the doctor couldn't
he was like if i put her under she's not
coming back up because she has a weak
heart and stuff so
it was a waiting game and we pushed it
as far as we can she started crying in
the night and stuff
so we got her the traditional filet
mignon dinner for the night before and
the morning of and then the doctor came
to the house that's a nice thing she
didn't have to leave she was here at the
home you know sometimes you have to
people don't get as lucky as we get with
a vet can't come to your house and you
have to bring
your pet to the vet and stuff and
you know for some people who've never
had a
dog or cat or any sort of uh
animal family member you know it's it's
easy to dismiss to be like oh you know
well
[ __ ] life goes on life is a series of
dogs and
it's tougher when you've spent
like a lot of your
life with
that animal when it goes beyond this is
a pet or this is a different species and
aren't dogs funny
into like that was one of our [ __ ]
kids man like
and we've now lost
four dogs and you know to old age real
old age
scully mulder louie and
mad martin marty
they all lived to be
deep double digits
mid double digits
like i think mulder was the oldest at
16.
is 16 that's a 16 year old kid man it's
like you can't just like
go back to life the next day there is a
hole a giant
emptiness um that
isn't as simple as being like oh i had a
i had a dog like no you lost a [ __ ]
family member and we grieved accordingly
like you know it was dark around this
house for for about a week
as much as i loved that dog and i spent
a lot of time taking care of that dog in
the last like
four months of her life and definitely
the last two months man um
that was jennifer's dog so jennifer like
took it super super [ __ ] hard so yeah
i mean it wasn't
the coven but post-christmas between
christmas and new year's
things got very very sad around here um
and you know i felt
i feel bad because there are people who
lose like real like human being
relatives and stuff and i ain't taking
anything away from any of those people
but
yeah i felt like i lost a family member
it it hit pretty damn hard and this was
a dog who i haven't spent
16 years with we had her for we figured
out like when she passed about five and
a half months about five and a half
years by the time
we got her and we got her as one of
those like [ __ ]
dogs that they show on the in the arms
of the egg like one of those commercial
dogs sarah mclaughlin dog yeah she's a
sarah
she was so [ __ ] bone thin and [ __ ]
and nursed her back to health and stuff
but uh
yeah hayden's just really hated to see
her go and you know there's one dog left
shecky last dog standing she turns 17
this year
um
you know you sign up for these things
and
there's the tacit agreement that like
one day your heart's gonna get broken we
don't do that with people
people coming in our lives or if we have
kids there's no understanding that like
one day i'm
i'm going to see all of your life
and you're not going to see all of mine
like
crushes me
so
yeah it was it was tough
um but other than that good i spent a
lot of time writing back to my point
to stay out of that to stay out of the
you know
not destructive but very sad mindset
um
and instead of doom scrolling about like
you know the [ __ ]
health about the
that
coveted [ __ ]
i just dove into writing i've been
writing comic book scripts for this
thing i'll be talking about soon
and uh oh my god i've been having such a
good time
such a good time uh you know i've ever
once
i've got a job as as kevin smith
like that's what i do for a living and i
forget from time to time that this all
started with a boy who wanted to write
so badly who like words were magic to
him and and
those magic words took him this far in
life so
getting back into the groove of writing
was absolutely wonderful i mean i wrote
clerks
three last year this time and then i did
a full a few drafts throughout the year
before we made the flick and whatnot uh
and then i've written some other stuff
that was
um fun but like work oriented but this
was me just like
having a blast again and
reveling in an art form where you don't
have to [ __ ] think about how much
it's gonna cost or you know are these
people alive still or you know anything
like that because it's
right there on the page so that has been
uh very therapeutic for me a lot of that
and hopefully soon i'll be able to
tell folks what i've been writing for
it's very very exciting
fun
hooray um all right but enough about me
and my [ __ ] let's talk about the
important things
yes
um what do we do first should we go dive
into the fat
we could fit it
we can do the fit there's there's like
an fyi boys and girls there's almost no
news this week um
there's been a it is the the end of the
year to the beginning of the year
hollywood ultimately shuts down
between like
thanksgiving and new year's but
definitely between christmas and new
year's
so nothing really happened there'd been
no announcements that are particularly
cool there might have been a thing or
two that's up to the cracks but they
were so cracky that i couldn't even find
them the one thing that i saw was that
the cw apparently is being put on the
block for sale
um
which is a big deal
um
a majority ship
warner brothers is going to sell
cw off
warner brothers is going to sell their
majority share i believe in the cw i'm
sure they'll keep a piece of it but it
won't be quote unquote their network it
was always like
a cw like
it was kind of the cbs meets warner
brothers amalgam there was some viacom
shareholderiness there was some warner
brothers shareholding venus it was
always a bit of a of a network caught
between two worlds
um
but if warner brothers sort of
relinquishes
its its majority to hold it on it
will all of the dc shows remain on the
cw
is is a relatively big question will
they go to hbo hbo max will they will
they become streamer only it's all of
this is unclear it's all relatively new
there's no buyer yet
um and even if somebody decides they do
want to buy it it's going to be a long
time in regulations and approvals and
all that stuff but
it is worth noting that that this giant
network
is uh is going to go onto the block
um
why do you think
like in a world where hbo max or warner
brothers
you know
merged with discovery
and they created this gigantic
you know uber conglomerate company
entertainment giant
why would you divest of any piece of
that let alone one that at least from
the outside has seemed very successful
you know the only insight that one could
have is from the outside it does but
maybe from the inside it isn't
you know maybe the desire to
to become streamers or the very least
basic cable
is is
it might be an expense that they don't
want to carry anymore
you know and maybe looking at the
ratings for your average cw show
they don't light up the world the way
they might once have
in the past
um
and so when something like
you know
riverdale does exponentially better on
netflix than it did on the cw
um it becomes then why are we not
putting a thing like riverdale on hbo
max why are we even bothering with the
cw if there's if there's if we can't get
enough viewers to make the ads
profitable enough is this an enterprise
that seems like it's it's earning its
keep
and somebody must have decided the
answer to that was no or the very least
the answer was let's look at it and see
if anybody wants to have this
i suspect i suspect it won't
it won't mean the end of it'll probably
mean the end of some cwdc
things but like even if the somebody buy
cw and those programs or the dc
properties don't go along
it seems like
warner brothers now has their
outlet like you know with with hbo
max like lois was that was superman and
lois
went right there
i think this like day after it aired on
cw right or something like yeah and it
was always like
i
it's unclear to me whether or not it was
going to be an hbo max show that also
appeared on the cw or vice versa um i
think i think it was a cw first and hbo
max but i do think that once this cycle
of dc shows is over if the cw is no
longer in the warner brothers fold they
will keep making dc shows but like the
green lantern core show that they're
working on is going to be for hbo max
the constantine reboot that jj is doing
is going to be on hbo max like all of
that stuff is going to be feeding that
beast as opposed to the cw
and so like yeah i don't think we'll
stop seeing it i just don't think we'll
see it on the on the terrestrial air the
way we're used to
um
interesting uh there were some other
stories the did you see the
punisher's change of wardrobe
i think he lost his uh his skull right
and he's well they're changing their
character entirely where i shouldn't say
changing they're evolving the character
entirely he's becoming
um
uh the uh
he's joining the hand
uh which in the marvel universe is the
the uh
how would you describe the yakuza gang
no they're they're like yakuza meets
ninjas meets you know
clubhouse
you know it took me far too long to
realize that the foot
in tina's ninja turtles was just a play
on the hand yeah
like not i'm not today years old when i
discovered that but it was way deeper
into my life
the uh the
frank castle
you know as most people watching this
show would know uh has been around the
marvel universe for a long time and he
was uh
a war vet vietnam vet who uh his
family gets killed in the park by
organized criminals he's the very
definition of a vigilante uh he's batman
but with you know different
circumstances no money
uh he loses his loved ones and then
starts a one-man war on crime this
character has been insanely popular for
decades
he's recognizable by the skull on his
chest apparently the skull on his chest
became problematic has been co-opted by
some folks that i guess
marvel
doesn't want to be associated with so
this seems like their fix which is
uh
also i guess the character you know in
more recent years has come under fire
for all the gun use and stuff and
[Music]
um so what they've done is they've
changed the skull uh to a proprietary
looking skull like that's the other
reason like
uh marvel slash disney can't own or
copyright or trademark the image of a
skull as seen on the punisher
because it's just too close to a regular
skull by adding the horns and stuff that
is their punisher logo now um and also
removes them from
the punisher logo as it's traveled in
the world of places they don't want to
be associated with frank castle no
longer using guns
or machine guns or any sort of guns uh
he's all swords now because the hand
they were they're all swords and stuff
um naturally some folks very upset uh i
don't read the comics so i you know
can't i got no skin in the game but as a
longtime comic book reader this is what
i'll say if you wait long enough kids
everything
comes back around this is not the first
time
that that frank castle's been turned
into like a different version of the
punisher they did this when we did
marvel nights they did like frank castle
got killed went to hell came back as a
guy who would only kill
bad people and monsters like
supernatural characters and stuff like
that
um you know it's a character that
sometimes based on the culture has be as
you know butted up against the culture
and so marvel has tried to find ways to
still keep a beloved character viable
while you know uh not being associated
with whatever they don't want to be
associated with this is yet another
example of that so if you're like oh i
can't stand what they're doing
let
take it from an old comic book fan
just wait 10 minutes
like nothing is forever kids that you
think that skull is gone from the
punisher's chest forever
no and when they put it back on his
chest they will sell a bazillion copies
for the welcome back so
it rather than feed the rage machine
just be like you know what
i i bet you
will see that skull again something
tells me you will something tells me
you'll see guns back in frank castle the
punisher's hands
one day but right now they're trying
something different and anytime a
company tries something different
it's good they're being creative
um yeah i'm surprised they didn't
kill him
and in the same way that all of those
things you said the logic still applies
you can kill a character let them lay
fallow for a few years and then bring
them back to greater plum great sales
the guy you you are loathed was gone is
has returned with a new mission a new
outlook on life was mary tyler moore but
with guns
you know whatever that is um but i feel
like if you're if you're looking to
quell that conversation then the death
of a character is pretty strong and you
just got to stick to it for a little bit
not forever
not even like a long time
but just long enough
to make people miss it that's not what
they're doing they're not they're not
doing that here
you know which is one of those like
yeah all right sure he's gonna be using
swords but then is he the punisher
anymore or is he just like a guy with
swords
that's i mean look characters can evolve
and change they're characters that start
as one thing and become something else
robin became nightwing you know uh
yeah you know
there are
i'm sure there are many uh but this is
this is an example of something they
could have done frank castle could have
become something else but
for their to their credit they're like
look rather than just kill him off and
rather than just
like uh you know
move him to some you know we'll try this
we'll we'll time in at least it ties
into existing marvel lore like we'll
time it in the hand for a while we'll
use swords and then if everyone hates it
we'll sell a million books when we go
back
so i'm not
i wasn't losing sleep over regardless
but
as an old hand at this kids don't that's
why you know when people got mad at
masters of the universe i was like just
wait five minutes there's another one
come literally one came like a few
months after us and one month after so
yeah these these this ip is so strong so
powerful
that
they'll be other other iterations um
yeah
you know and also if if you are an old
comic book hand you know that every
character that you currently love was
introduced in a fashion that would make
you blush if you looked at it
you know like blade is a super cool
character the blade from tomb of dracula
is like an avenging disco godfather
and over time and through lots of hands
and writers like it evolved and changed
and shifted
black panther
sure okay i mean jack and stan had some
thoughts about it
um but you know i'm not going to say
they were the most penetrating insights
into
african uh you know uncolonized africa
created by two jewish guys in new york
i'm just saying it didn't go that deep
um the bones were there for somebody to
eventually pick it up and make it great
and make it the thing that you
recognized um but yeah everything needs
to evolve everything needs to change and
perhaps it's time for the punisher to do
just that
um looking at chat they'll always tell
us what we missed as well
uh there's a boys season three
teaser trailer that just dropped today
we'd show it but naturally they'd throw
us off youtube and arrest us we can't
ever show videos here for some reason
we've tried to show [ __ ] videos for
my own things and we've got thrown off
youtube and getting citations i don't
know what
what button we have to press to do away
with that but but regardless you can go
find that boy's
teaser right now i watched his [ __ ]
quick but um you know it's just a date
announcement more than anything but that
season three is coming in june
but uh but it's new footage it ain't old
so
technically a sneak
um but it did make me like ooh
i'm ready for that and then i was like
when [ __ ] june
counting on me to be alive till june
when is uh when's doctor strange come
out
um i think it's may if i remember
correctly they just moved morbius to
april first
now i've read a story and who knows if
this is conjecture but the move had less
to do with the cron and more to do with
the mon as in spider-man who is making
all the money at the box office sony's
like [ __ ] this and they just moved
morbius so that no way home could
continue earning did you read that
um i i didn't read it it just it
astonishes me though that like
it feels morbius feels like it's a made
for streaming movie
you know like i don't know maybe it's
because i i never really got down with
the venom and so this sort of stony
spider-man extension universe never
really appealed to me that much um
you know it seems as if what you would
want is people who are currently excited
about spider-man to give them
immediately a thing that they would want
to capitalize on that excitement about
spider-man which i'm sure was the
initial idea which they put out in
january just after people saw spiderman
it'll be fresh in their minds
and so yeah i don't
i don't know although april fool's day
does seem like a perfectly good day to
release a movie like morbius the living
vampire
uh okay
no i mean
the chat has been blowing up with like
hey man [ __ ] talk about ben affleck
and i
you know
i i i do talk about ben but like
you know this weekend
yeah i said something this week or
somewhere about like um oh it was on the
last [ __ ] show we did where i was
like look like he's he's already said he
doesn't want to do this anymore so
you know they chose michael keaton
because it's either you bring a brand
new batman in or at least you go to make
the premise
work of
the flash movie in terms of the you know
multiple worlds and whatnot and then to
make their background movie work where
they need an older batman to train a
younger back girl
i my point was
you know michael keaton does make sense
particularly chiefly because i said ben
didn't want to do it and i don't
i i was saying it based on everything
that has been publicly available and yes
some things that i know that aren't
publicly available as well
but uh some folks you know wrote
articles and then [ __ ] were like came
after me again with pitches and torch
pitchers and torches the idea being that
i was poo pooing ben as batman not at
all but it's like ben is
i thought ben made it very clear in the
press and and at least to me that he was
like no that i'm done with that
so
there's an article that is up and it's
on comicbook.com
so
and it's on it's a bun it's all over the
website so let's see
the
headline is
ex-batman actor ben affleck had the
quote
worst experience
making justice leagues
justice league sorry i sound like a
grandfather how was the justice leagues
um i mean because i'm looking at the
source for that and it's an l.a times
interview it's not like that's the
important part of the story is this is a
legit source correct it is um the quote
is
uh it was really justice league that was
the nadir for me that was a bad
experience because of confidence of
things
my own life my divorce being way too
much the competing agendas and then
zack's personal tragedy um and the
re-shooting it was it just was the worst
experience it was awful it was
everything that i didn't like about this
that became the moment where i said i'm
not doing this anymore
it's not even about like justice league
was so bad because it could have been
anything
wow
yeah
um so
which so it's when he says justice
league which is he talking about
joss whedon's justice league yeah i
think so i think you know
she said justice league was the nadir so
the the worst part of it
you know
and all of the things that happened with
justice league that that made it just a
whole kitten caboodle of it was just i'm
not happy doing this stuff
you said that about directing batman
it's like i looked at it and thought i'm
not going to be happy doing this the
person who does this shouldn't love it
you're always supposed to want these
things and i probably would have loved
doing it at 32 or something but it was
the point where i started to realize
it's not worth it it's just a wonderful
benefit of reorienting and recalibrating
your priorities but once it started
being more about the experience i felt
more at ease
so yeah i mean ben has explained in what
seems to be relatively clear fashion i
don't want to do these anymore
you know like and justice league was an
awful experience for him for all of
those reasons
you know personal reasons professional
reasons and he recalibrated and reset
his priorities and said i just don't
want to do it
it's not that he was bad at it it's not
that the internet didn't like it it's
not that the grosses were bad or
anything it was just for him this is not
how i want to spend
you know the sort of mid-period of my
life
absolutely fair and something that he's
said in one version of or another he
didn't he didn't go as deep as he went
this time but
he made it clear a while ago that he's
like yeah no i don't want to do
stuff like that anymore
um
so
what happens now to the folks that are
like you know
affleck or nothing like you know the
people who are mad about michael keaton
it's like does that make you less mad do
you go oh
or
does it matter
i mean you you would think
you know two plus two equals before
the guy that they are championing to
want to do batman doesn't want to do it
anymore so they would stand down
you know just like you know what all
right we were wrong we thought we were
taking something from him but it turns
out it's something he doesn't want
um i imagine that
if the sort of conspiracy theorist
will gathering world that we live in
will be
the man is telling us this story like he
can't like blink if they're holding you
hostage pen because that doesn't sound
like the batman that i know like there's
a narrative that makes that seem as if
it's some kind of you know
conspiracy or cover-up or conjecture or
whatever
but sometimes you just gotta let it go
sometimes you don't get what you want
and that's fine that's what life is
or like or also as we've seen michael
keaton just came back as [ __ ] batman
just
wait 10 20 minutes man there's a world
where [ __ ] like 10 years from now
they're like ben come back and do batman
because it makes sense in this movie and
he's in a different mindset and he's
like all right yeah let's do it
i'll tell you man i'm trying to see the
sunny side of the street
so if he's out
as batman maybe that means he's in his
daredevil over at marvel
[Laughter]
now they got that multiverse going man
maybe if someone opens a door and it's
ben affleck matt murdock he sounds like
he's just done doing superhero stuff
i texted him
he's uh hmm
we worked together fairly recently and
um there was a
uh afterwards i was texting being like
you're so like you're having a good time
you're in a great
performance space right now the tender
bar the last duel the thing that he did
with us
just he's so
like in a comfy zone place
and he said like you know it's weird
just when i'm starting to think about
concentrating on directing
he found like of an acting mode vibe
where he's like
he he hit his he hit his moment where
he's just like oh i
i know what i'm doing like after years
and years and years but um it's it's
been nice to see him kind of
having a good time performance wise i
mean there's the world in which that
dude just sort of blossoms into like
clint eastwood
you know who's like i know my speed i
know how i perform the most on screen i
know what looks good for me on screen i
love to direct if i can do them both
great sometimes i'll show up an active
thing because it's fun not going to take
a lot out of me and i can do the thing
that i do well and then i want to go
make these movies and i'll make them
fast and that's my life and i have a
really good time doing all of it and
that is a perfectly good target to aim
for that dude is still [ __ ] making
movies in his 90s
and he's you know like why not why don't
you find what you like and go do that
same studio too like you know
warner brothers is home forever uh
warner brothers loves ben like and he
honestly
like after
the town
after gone baby got gone baby gone
the town and gone girl not gone girl uh
the town and argo
like it looked like oh my god he is
gonna be young clint eastwood and stuff
and then after argo that's when
batman v superman came calling and stuff
so i feel like you know he was like this
has been fun but now i'm i'm gonna go
back to like what i was doing and stuff
um and you know that mixture of being
able to write and direct like kind of
grown up fair he makes very grown up
movies like all those movies he made
were very gone baby
gone baby gone
town and argo are inarguably more mature
movies than anything i've [ __ ] made
like and and i don't mean like you know
they're not juvenile although they're
not that they're just accomplished
they're serious adult like drama my
parents would have went to see those
movies in the movie theater when i was a
kid they would not have gone to see
[ __ ] kevin smith movies so he's got a
you know
he's got a future that affleck i think i
think we're gonna be hearing from that
young wrestler and i don't mean a
postcard
yeah i mean i think we we just we live
currently in this place
where fans
expect things to go on forever
and they expect in one fashion or
another to get what they want
and
that has never been the case you know
all good things come to an end like
every every iteration of a thing that
you love
fades and the people who make them stop
making them the people who are in them
stop wanting to be in them sometimes
because they want it sometimes because
they don't sometimes because they pass
away
but everything has to end and so if this
was the end of ben's run as batman and
it's on his terms and he's at peace with
it
then like let it go
you'll have another batman again in like
six months
there's a new batman will you love this
guy as much you love him who knows if
you didn't like him there will be
another one six years from now that
isn't robert patton's because they will
never let batman die
so like to your point just wait a little
bit you're going to get a new one but
we're going to
we're getting ever closer
to the inevitable bat
when jon hamm finally puts on the suit
you know and and yeah like there's the
world in which when ben at 65 who's
still in great shape decides you know
what now's the time for the dark knight
returns now i'm old enough to tell this
story
that i couldn't have told before
and then go do that
looks great ben's back to tell the last
batman story
and [ __ ] it i'd be here for that i'd be
here if clint still wants to do that
well not really
if clooney decided he wants to like
[ __ ] be all at batman [ __ ] give me
that
michael keaton
especially if he was like i have
something to prove i have a story to
tell
yeah um
all right so yeah wow that was that was
like a breaking story
yes more news than we thought there was
yeah man is there any other news uh
oh banff man is in what you got oh the
how is everything in chat
uh chat looks pretty good people are
talking
i'm sure we'll get to it at the end a
lot of people died this week
but um
like famous people
did they really i mean less less in our
sphere but betty white passed away
um and today
um sidney poitier died that's right
uh peter bogdanovich also
oh my god gaganovich died as well
yeah how old was peter bogdanovich
he's the late 80s i thought or 82 83 a
lot of people dr melfi's psychiatrist in
the sopranos but uh that was one of our
most celebrated american filmmakers
for years 82.
yeah it was
99 was very white
sydney party was 94. and then the
bogdanovich was 82.
wow
uh ben white of course is uh you know a
huge loss especially so close to her
birthday but his nice her 100th birthday
but as i saw many people online were
like hey man if you count all the time
she was in the womb she made it 100
years
and then i saw one that was like hey man
if you take off those [ __ ] [ __ ]
leap years she made it to a hundred
it was very important for for
all of us that she got to that number
and stuff and people were doing math and
writing algorithms to make it happen
show you how beloved she was i spent a
few days
you know uh falling down the rabbit hole
of her stuff on on youtube and what a
lovely human being she was jason muse
put up a [ __ ] photo
of him with her and i was like when did
you work with
with [ __ ] betty white like i know you
when did you work with betty white and
he's like did you notice barack obama in
the background and it was at a wax
museum
i hadn't i hadn't really like
i did but i didn't put together like why
would obama be
[ __ ] photobombing jay's photo this is
a fundraiser or something like how much
did jay give to obama's campaign to get
to this house
was him and betty white and obama like
did he go to like the national arts
endowment foundation gala whether what
does he do when he's not standing next
to me in movies and and in real life
um and cindy poitier of course has an
amazing historical body of work but one
of my favorite performances of his is
from sneakers remember sneakers so much
fun so much fun and he was having a good
time too because you're talking about
you know they call me mr tits one of the
most
celebrated actors of his day who got to
be a little goofy in that in that movie
as well yeah like the straight man who's
sort of loosened up a bit
um
yeah it's it's really really fun it's if
you've never seen sneakers it is 100
worth watching if for no other reason
then yeah well there's a ton of reasons
but
um president rosalind in her young sexy
ass self
um the late river phoenix uh having a
blast
um
dan aykroyd without belushi for one of
the first times and like funny as [ __ ]
you know david shafarin playing a blind
computer hacker
and robert
robert redford just being charm city man
and ben kingsley
as the
quote like spoilers the bad guy yeah
such a good movie um
man that is that's uh wait who is the
other person it's betty white and
bogdanovic peterborough convention we
spoke about him may i speak about
someone in my world that passed away
please do rob bruce who was a our pop
culturalist he introduced me to the term
hop culturalist from time to time you
know uh i've used it uh on myself to be
like oh i'm a pop culturalist
uh pop culturalist uh rob bruce who uh
was uh one of the producers a creative
producer
on comic book men uh most of our seasons
of comic book men
um he was a he passed away uh recently
uh he's a jersey uh uh resident uh round
from our neck of the woods had this
great story called groove spot and was
very tight with walter flanagan who ran
secret stash and star of comic book men
and so walter
brought rob into into my world and um
before the tv show even he would talk
about this guy he's like well rob bruce
has this rob bruce has this man i
haven't seen this in years but rob bruce
has a copy so when we started comic book
man we brought in rob bruce as like
consulting creative producer
and uh he was always around sometimes he
was on camera with us i can't remember
how many episodes he was on with us
but he was absolutely lovely dude the
lovely families
great kids um who were around when we
shot the show amc at one point when they
started comic book men
season one they had a lot of like uh
unscripted shows
that they did that see like a bunch of
shows
and so
after season one of comic book men i
think it was or maybe season two
they were like um we're going to try to
spin off rob bruce and his family
because they go to like swap meets and
stuff like that and they thought it was
really interesting
so they shot like a sizzle reel but then
amc killed its entire unscripted
division except for like
and and the talking dead
and so uh it kind of went away which i
always felt bad about because he did
live a really really interesting life uh
this guy had everything everything you
lost in childhood he had
um in his in his first in his store and
then later in his storage facility
but a wonderful dude man uh and uh died
way too
young way too early and
and alone as nobody could die alone um
so rest in peace rob bruce thank you for
helping me make my tv show i mean you
know that's the thing it's like i
like i had
for years people like hey i watch your
show and you know i'd be like thanks but
i was just one element
on the show and and the least important
i would show up
like toward the end of it they would
shoot that entire show without me like
all the stuff in the store or where the
boys went off and did things
um and then i would come in and just
shoot for two or three days for a wrap
around
around the table like and
and for that little
work
i was afforded what was called my tv
show for all intense purposes people
were like oh i saw your tv show and rob
bruce helped me make my tv show but
really i you know it was their tv show i
i was just a guest on it
um so i'm glad he got
you know it's not like everybody needs
to be on tv or in the focus of the
public guy or get a little attention but
for his expertise in the field it was
nice that we were able to
showcase i'm hit i'm glad he was
showcased everybody
has something special about him and we
were able to showcase something that was
really special about rob
so uh we'll miss him um
around our parts and elsewhere
uh rob bruce passed away far too early
amen amen
uh okay
um
so here's here's what's left on the
docket okay
um
boba fett which we have yet to talk
about for reals um
uh i can i can probably hold on to my
top 10 of 2021 list
for next episode because there's still
honestly a couple things i want to watch
um
so we can we can do our second ad we can
get into boba fett and then we can do q
a does that sound good let's do that
let's do add and then uh we'll get into
boba fett and then uh q a
perfect
our second ad
our other ad because they're not second
they're there right there first in our
hearts
are the good boys and girls at native oh
we love native i just literally used
native products to shower this morning
kids so
uh i can vouch for these cats man um i'm
not ordering them as we speak because
they send it to me for free
uh it's a new year and who doesn't want
to make some easy changes to their
personal hygiene routine to make it a
little cleaner mint that's where native
comes in
natives aluminum-free deodorant body
washes are never made with parabens or
sulfates uh and they're both
a customer favorite classic deodorant
native also offers sensitive and plastic
free options the sensitive formula is
made without baking soda for those with
more sensitive skin and the packaging
for the plastic free deodorant is made
of 100
paper board that's cause that's
considerate as [ __ ] and smart
if you can't get enough of native scents
try their body wash man or body wash as
jason muse calls it available in eight
cents their body washes have a rich
lather that leaves skin feeling
moisturized and conditioned
uh long after you take your clothes off
and get in the shower and then get out
of the shower and get dressed you're
still feeling it
is that how the process works i'm an
alien from a different planet and i'm
explaining it for the first time as i've
been told yes
the kickoff this new year uh to kick off
the new year native has partnered with
baked by melissa
for a collection of scents inspired by
baked by melissa's delicious cupcake
creations man so you can choose from tie
dye vanilla cupcake mint cookie cupcake
fresh peach cupcake ginger lemon uh
lemonade cupcake to make your day a
little sweeter man that means you'll be
like washing up with scents
that smell like cupcakes you will smell
like a bakery and who don't want that
that fresh peach cupcake sounds dirty
and delicious it really does yeah i mean
what a
what a sexy choice uh for the good folks
native uh in their collab
with uh
baked by melissa uh this year
up your personal hygiene routine kids
with native go native man go to native
d-e-o
dot com slash fat man that is native d
e
o dot com
slash uh fat man or use the promo code
fat man at checkout you're gonna get 20
off your first order man that's
nativedeo.com
kids slash fat man or use the promo code
fat man check out for 20 off your first
order we thank the good folks at native
um for uh as always sponsoring uh uh our
uh james um
fat man beyond i'm looking at the actual
a product that they put out with uh
with uh baked by melissa and the bottom
the bottles look different they're
they're very colorful very rainbow very
baked by melissa
the deodorant ladies and gentlemen use
them please i we legit use them in this
house and when they stop sending me free
product well i'll just buy it my damn
self because i like it that much i'm
getting used to it
i've gotten used to it i dig it
so there it is kids native
go you know what go by native right now
we're gonna wait for the next five
minutes while you all make it
let's sit here and style it
um all right let's talk about the fat
let's feed the fat or fet the fet if you
will
um we had dave
earlier if you if you guys are coming in
late
uh the great dave klein uh who's uh shot
episode one of boba fett and shot
episode six of mandalorian season two
where
boba fett showed up for the first time
in a long time
two episodes available right now uh on
disney plus
um
this is uh spun out of the mandalorian
as we saw boba at the end of
season two of the mandalorian lay claim
to the throne of job of the hutt and
he's going to take over as uh an
underworld leader of the underworld on
tatooine and so
what we were promised was a show set in
the crime world
of the star wars galaxy and uh it seems
to be what they're putting together
um
i
love
the show
not saying a lot
i love everything i'm not a very
discerning customer and [ __ ] but
i watched it with my wife who i had to
talk into watching it
and she
dug it at the end she was like oh [ __ ]
this is actually good i was like right
now will you watch mandalorian with me
i'll go back and watch the whole [ __ ]
thing with you
um i thought even hitting the ground
running with klein's episode man with
which has a lot of outdoor stuff which
is [ __ ]
gorgeous and legit looks like star wars
um i was in there's some [ __ ] that i was
like man do we have to see his face so
much
but
by episode two i didn't care about
seeing his face so much
episode two i really feel like they got
the wind under their wings man and and
suddenly
something that they did in episode one
which they did some flashback stuff to
how
he got out of the the sarlacc pit which
wasn't very far removed
from how he got out of the sarlacc pit
in that old episode of an old issue of
marvel comics that star wars did back in
like 1983 1984 that i absolutely loved
where he got out of that a bit he had no
memory he became like buddied up with
han solo and then he got his memory back
and he was like solo and then he got
knocked into the sarlacc pit again and
so he wounds up right where he started
perfect comic story put him right where
he [ __ ] began leave everything right
where it was but this
did a similar thing with like holy [ __ ]
he got out i loved seeing that i loved
seeing him in the [ __ ] song but i
loved seeing the [ __ ] sail barge that
was left behind of course all the
callbacks [ __ ] i absolutely loved um but
what they started doing in episode one
is they tell the current story of him
taking over tattooing
and then they flash back whenever he's
in the back to tank to how he kind of
got there how he got out of the sarlacc
pit what happened to him in the
intervening years which i think is kind
of smart because it lets you know hey
there is a present to this show
but
here's all the past stuff you could have
done a version where you just
took them from the sarlacc pit all the
way to wherever they take them
but we know where he winds up as we saw
in mando
season two so it was an interesting
choice uh to do what they did and i
am
fascinated once again john favreau find
something in the star wars universe to
dive deep on and make me appreciate more
than i ever did before
he is absolutely embraced the tuscan
raiders the sand people and is making a
[ __ ] pretty fascinating show
very 70s it feels so [ __ ] like kung
fu or planet of the apes tv show to me
about like you know
this stranger from strange land learning
the ways of this culture
um and them getting him back on his feet
i
you know he's still a very interesting
character but like all throughout
episode two
i was like i'd watch a whole [ __ ]
season of this man who knew that i could
spend so much time like with the sand
people just shows you like anything in a
good writer's hands can turn it
interesting again
so i love what they've done so far
um again i would i would like to see him
keep his helmet on more in the present
um i think i saw something about like uh
what's his name joe johnson is that the
guy
he said the same thing i never would
have took his helmet off
um but it's not because i'm like you
know oh
[ __ ] i don't want to see this guy i mean
we do a whole other show where the guy
doesn't take his helmet off so clearly
it could work
um it's just you know i grew up from
childhood with boba fett we never saw
his [ __ ] face until those
prequels and stuff so it was a little
jarring at first for me in episode one
where it's like put it out put your
helmet on he got in a whole [ __ ]
fight in episode one without his helmet
on i was like oh my god what are you
doing man put your helmet on like i
don't want to see some some uh bald dude
fight i don't see boba fett fight but by
episode two that bias went away where i
was like oh i will watch this ball do
fight i will fight what is his name
tamara morrison
i will like i'm i'm in i dig his
performance episode one i was like
that's aquaman's dad episode two
i'm there he's he's he's sucked me in i
i think episode two was
easily uh stronger than episode one in
terms of the writing and stuff episode
one just gets the thing up and running
uh but episode two it fully takes flight
i was in by episode one but episode two
i was like ah my interest was warranted
i can't wait to see where it goes i
thought we'd see some more killing
because when we saw him
in you know
in mandel he was a gaffy sticking
[ __ ] storm troopers to death and for
some reason in this show he's like i'm
not gonna rule with fear i'm a rule of
respect and it's like yeah but i'm
hoping it's a bit of that coward of the
county [ __ ] where he's like in the
beginning he's like i ain't gonna do it
but by the end he's like [ __ ] and he
just starts cutting heads off and [ __ ]
um we'll see
but if it if it don't come to that i'm
still in i'm very satisfied with what
they're giving me man in fact the thrall
i watched episode two with the wife last
night
and you know she's a great
like [ __ ] bar for this [ __ ] because
i'm
you know me i'm like i love it all oh my
god they showed a bantha you know but
she's a lot more discerning and whatnot
and she's like i'm actually in i was
like right [ __ ] man
uh so i'm digging boba
you
i i i know enough now
uh through my experience with the
mandalorian
to not judge a star wars show from this
particular crew
too harshly at the beginning because i
know that there's always a long game
that they're playing and that there may
or may not be payoffs i'm hoping there
are i will say i did not expect my boba
fett show to be so much about meetings
because
lots of the front story of boba fett is
i'm gonna go talk to this guy and then
we have a meeting and then a bunch of
guys are coming to my house and we're
gonna have a meeting and i'm gonna walk
down the street to go have some more
meetings i'm gonna have a meeting in the
street and this would be a tense meeting
but it's a lot of like
just people talking about stuff maybe
that's why
maybe that's why i love it so much
because i'm like this is star wars i
could make
it's just people talking to each other
and i and i did see a tweet where a guy
was like imagine how weird it would be
if the first star wars show was about a
storm trooper and then the second star
wars show was like here's another storm
trooper like literally these two guys
the two leads of these two shows wear
the same [ __ ] helmet
and it's like oh so it's just another
one of the guys in these helmets oh
they're a little bit different oh really
nobody else wanted to do a show about
and as we all get there as we know from
the other show you know
he keeps his helmet on of course because
he's a member of the religion whereas
boba fett is not a member of the
religion that being said
because you know there's some people are
like hey man [ __ ] boba he gets to
take his helmet off you [ __ ] dumbass
because he ain't [ __ ] part of that
colt you [ __ ] i'm seeing a lot of
that in chat my point was
uh i grew up from 1983 forward with a
boba fett who never took his helmet off
so right you know yes i met a boba fett
who took his helmet off in the prequel
trilogies but i'm just saying
yes i'm used to boba fett with zombie i
understand and i as i said earlier i'm
okay with him taking his time it off by
the time we get to the second episode i
was like i'm way into it but for the
love of christ people
i know what i'm about yeah what the [ __ ]
man like you get corrected by a bunch of
people being like no don't you [ __ ]
get it he's not a part of the religion
you [ __ ] dumbass i'm like i i know i
was
anyway back to mark he was talking
i told mark i was gonna not interrupt
him this year people
and you [ __ ] made me look what you
made me do back to you you made me do it
um
i'm not as enamored with the the
flashback stuff i think
um because the the
yeah like
uh the the stuff in the second episode
you know the the boba of arabia stuff
which it is 100
lawrence of arabia somebody in chat i
wish i could find it but they called it
uh dances with sand people
and i was like oh my god that is like as
i i'm so stupid as i watch it i'm like
this is the most original thing i've
ever [ __ ] seen and then all one
person has to do is be like it's dances
of sand people i'm like that's why i
like it it reminds me of something that
i like very much but that's what he does
just like george lucas used to you know
bite from other storytellers or story uh
themes or whatnot um
here's favro doing a kind of similar
thing no yeah it's totally i mean it's
it's very much like lawrence of arabia
features like one of its best scenes is
is peter o'toole leading the arab army
as they take down a british train
right down to like blowing it up and
climbing on top of it and then he gets
the the reignment
of the arab world and he looks pretty
cool in it like
like yeah this is about them taking on a
train because it's lawrence of arabia
and of course it is
um
which you know
[Music]
never in a million years but to be fair
i'm the guy who watched don't look up
and had no idea it was about climate
change whatsoever
i'm not i'm not art i make art but i'm
not good at interpreting it or making it
depending on who you ask anyway back to
you mark yeah so like and i understand
what they're doing with the tuscan
raiders and i understand
the the sort of reclamation project i
think
that that sort of favron filoni and
robert rodriguez and dave klein are
doing which is the tuscan raiders
have often been like this weird like
sight gag or
the the the simple savages of the
tatooine world
and they're actually giving them a
culture and they're giving them you know
stories and characters and and religion
and creeds and all of that stuff like
they're making them real people which i
think is definitely worth doing
i think from a story perspective i keep
on wondering what the show wants to be
like does it want to be here's here's
boba fett
um
reclaiming tatooine as you know making
it lawful evil and not chaotic evil or
whatever he's going to turn it into you
know and the story it's like it's
godfather too it's young
[ __ ] vito corleone
hammering order onto the chaos that was
lower new york
when he forms you know what will
eventually be the five families like
it's it's and that's cool like young
mobster coming in doing some new [ __ ]
changing the game is super fun but every
time we cut back to like in episode one
it was you know i think i texted you
it's like jango's kid unchained where
it's like here he is like he's in chains
he's being dragged along like he's a
slave in a slave cart and then he gets
freed and all that stuff i'm like okay i
get it
this is how we get some of the tuscan
raiders and this next episode is here's
how he wins the hearts of the dozen
raiders because at some point boba fett
will be
alone and captured and somebody will say
to him you know there's nobody here on
this planet who gives a [ __ ] about you
you made enemies with everybody like
you're going to die here in the sands
alone and he was hell i'm not alone and
then uphill rise of tusken raiders and
that's his muscle the muscle will be the
tuscan raiders of whom he is you know a
sort of vaunted member of it i get it i
see where it's going
but it's just the fuel air mixture
between
the the front story which i'm invested
in and the back story which is filling
in blanks that you know i didn't need to
ever see him in the sarlacc pit
because much like the kessel run like
solo i think taught us quite a bit about
like maybe you don't need to see all the
things that have been like written as
legend of the past because it will never
be cooler than they are in your
imagination
you know the kessel run was not as cool
as it was as i thought it was in my head
the saw like pit was not as cool as it
was in my head it was fine like i get it
but
i would rather have that you got better
imagination than me because i was like
oh
he's in it he's being digesting over a
thousand years
but it's a thing that we already knew
happened like it doesn't add anything to
the story because we already knew it
existed
you know and so it just became like
you know not the worst kind of fan
service but it just became that like let
me show you the thing that you're going
to want to see like all right sure i get
it not surprising in any way really but
you're just giving me the thing
which if you dig it great i personally
didn't even need to see it
um
so i just i i wanted to start to engage
with its story a little bit more
um less filling in gaps and more
breaking new ground
you know and
and it found me sort of wondering
you know george lucas was very much
inspired by pulp storytelling you know
and i think that the cleanest
version of that is is a new hope which
begins so [ __ ] hot like it starts
with space combat it starts with vader
assaulting a ship it starts with the the
crazy escape of of of c-3po and r2d2 it
begins with all of this drama and action
and movement and acceleration
and raiders does the same thing like all
of these old pulps that they were drawn
from were breathless stories
and these don't feel drawn from that as
much as they do westerns which is also
fine
but this is another show where we're
starting kind of slow
and we're going to slowly find our feet
and we will eventually accelerate and we
will build to a finale that's pretty
cool and i know we will
because nobody here doesn't know their
job like favreau understands how to tell
stories robert rodriguez understands how
to tell stories all these guys are good
at this job
but i just kind of was hoping for a
different experience coming to the show
and not like another version of the same
experience
um
my living dog came running in
all good uh what about
let's talk about the other wookie
yes whose name i don't know because i
never had the star wars books but the
dark wookie
who who i saw like the internet lose its
[ __ ] mind and i'm like oh that guy
looks cool
but
i don't know what he means
other than is he from extended universe
literature or something like that
yeah i think he was in oh yeah here we
go
i never read this but apparently he's
from the dr aphra
comic book series that everybody loves
uh that i guess dr aphra is like the
indiana jones of star wars and the the
wookie is her
i don't know
salah
you know or her mark is brody
um and a couple of huts the the
were they the the twins
um who sat awfully close
um who looked like
it looked like they were trying to honor
uh the
reimagination of
of uh job of the hutt from the prequels
like those huts look closer to that
which i kind of
in my mind i was like oh man they're
paying homage to
to like the wonky
jabba that replaced you know the the
human the first time before they got it
down with science but i was happy to see
a couple huts i mean it's tattooing so i
guess it was a matter of time i am so
easy i realized that it's like you
basically
i look at that show and it looks like
they have the entire
set of action figures and all the toys
lined up and then they just pick out a
few and put them on the board and go
and everyone's like yeah and that's we
wind up with [ __ ] i didn't even see i
didn't know
like when he gets the lizard up his nose
and [ __ ] he becomes the lizard king he
goes tripping tripping the brain
chipping the brain
and he goes to the tree where he pulls
the stick and [ __ ] all those eyes that
lit up
it wasn't until the end credits when
they were showing the you know the
production art
that i saw they were all jawas i didn't
know that
and you know when they were
i was like oh they're all jawas and my
wife was like you didn't know that and i
was like [ __ ] man i'm getting old
you guys know that it was javas those
eyes lighting up
well i mean they were the ones who found
them to begin with like the one who
stripped his armor off of him i was like
oh yeah i guess they're joe's again
um but yeah like and and like again i
see what i see what they're doing i see
the pieces they're putting into place
it's it comes into this town and here
let's establish all of the various
pressure points here's the mayor who's
going to be an [ __ ] here's the club
owner who might be an ally but probably
won't be here the hutts who are the big
bads here's his little major dobo robot
who seems like he's going to be a little
shifty
like all of these things are eventually
threats that he will have to at some
point deal with in order for him to be
the daimyo of of mousespa you know okay
that's cool
they also had
cami
and fixer
who were two characters from the cut
scenes
of the first star wars like the hung out
with biggs and luke and [ __ ] like
they're in this as well
somebody here on chat mr duck sauce says
this is about the wookie black curran
crannies cr
chrysanthemum maybe that's it's
k-r-r-s-a-n-t-a-n
black chrysanthemum was an exiled wookie
from kashyyyk who rose to the ranks of
the underworld as a gladiator
and then became a bounty hunter and
guard for other scum
and villainy i mean that's dope man when
you're just grabbing deep cut [ __ ] like
that so even somebody
like i didn't know that so some hardcore
star wars did you know that banff man
did you know who that guy was no because
i didn't ever read those that's like a
disney era comic and i've kind of like
not kept up the same with
when they were like uh when bob iger was
like star wars has not yet begun to get
marketed and then they release like four
million stories a month i was like i
can't keep up with this i'm too old um
so i did not know that although i did
recognize
fixer and cami and that was my like
they saw the same thing off the behind
the magic dvd that i couldn't wait to
get in 1995 and i got it for my cd-rom
drive and i saw it and it was the best
thing ever um although people are saying
that was the tachi station i don't
believe it's the tachi station because
if you watch
the deleted scenes they show you the
actual tachi station in those
um which i think they have them on
disney plus right now and it's not the
same building this would be years after
the events in star wars correct
uh
yeah it would have been like eight years
after so those characters
it could be them just in a different
part of they've just i mean they're you
know instead of being 25 they're 35 or
whatever but i don't think it's the same
tachi station didn't have a bar like
that had like intergalactic pool tables
i don't think it's the same building
i think ever do you think they ever give
us bigs
i mean he dies
in episode four
so
you'd have to do it star wars
yeah he dies at the end of episode four
did you know he was in tim burton's bat
the actor was in tim burton's batman he
plays plays the dad harold at the
beginning is biggs dark lighter
the the takes the muggers on the roof
it's actually fighter yeah i just found
that out yesterday when i was watching
batman
um wild
so i guess
if it's not toshitashi station is it
meant to be anchor head wasn't that
another [ __ ] word in the
well tachi station was like a
hangout in anchor head in anchorage can
i give a hot a hot take on on power
converters
if you read if you read the star wars
novel
everybody's like luke is going to the
tachi station to pick up some power
converters right
if you read the novel apparently that
was a lie that luke was telling to his
uncle meaning he wanted and then owen
says you can waste time with your
friends when your chores are done luke
is lying to his uncle saying i'm gonna
go pick up
i'm gonna go to the hardware store
to get stuff for the farm and his
uncle's like no you're not you're going
to play video games with your friend but
everybody thinks that luke is just
whining there but he's actually lying
to his to his uncle
not actually he's not he never intended
to go and pick up power converters he
intended to go and play video games or
whatever
yeah
anyway i do think either way
it was an excuse to go drinking kind of
thing yeah he was going out to party
um
do you think that they're going to add a
build your own gaffy stick to galaxy's
edge
after that
it would take a long time
yeah the peyote side trip for you to go
and have your vision quest to find the
right stick
it helps if you know how to bevel wood
i did like that scene though i had no
idea there was wood and a gaffy stick i
just thought they were like metal rods
the uh i dug all that the the scene
where he's making that i pulled an image
it's straight out of ralph mcquarrie so
i'll put that up
if you see it
and that's oh my god
so that ralph report drawing was from
70s yeah ages ago yeah 40 some odd years
ago and then they just took it and put
it in uh
wow i mean come on there's having such a
good [ __ ] time over there
like just nerding the [ __ ] out like
going like ooh let's replicate this deep
cuts thing
like i guess it's like dave said he's
like every decision they're like what
would george do where would george put
the camera and um
that's so dope man i i enjoy it hats off
abs john favreau he's having a [ __ ]
good time and i'm having i like
if i went over favreau's house as a kid
i would watch him play with his star
wars toys i wouldn't be in there i
wouldn't be like well no he does this
i'd be like what else does he do
yeah i i'm just i'm looking for you know
if i get the internet knows this i'm
just looking for it to become the thing
that it's going to be
and first you know early stages are
always hard to judge because they have a
plan and they're executing it at their
pace and their speed you know my my
personal taste is for a little bit more
speed and more pulp
you know i think that
the lack of a uh replacement for baby
yoda
which did wonders for that first season
of the mandalorian you know like oh
there's a little slug look at that
[ __ ] baby yoda i [ __ ] love that
baby
don't you ever heard the baby yoda we
don't have no baby odor yet you know
there's nothing here that i care that
much about
um aside from maybe
excited for maybe fennec boba hasn't
given you a baby yoda yet oh yeah i
don't have any emotional core to this
yet you know it's all still very
academic it's all still very i hope he
can you know unite the gangs or i hope
he can hold on to jabba's palace because
he seems to want it although i don't
know why
you know like i i hope he gets in good
with the tusken raiders they seem like
nice folks you know okay sure but like i
don't yet know the big story the
emotional story we're telling
and baby yoda was a perfect way to just
you know
gloss over that with if anything happens
to that [ __ ] baby i will flip this
metaphorical table and maybe a real one
or two so don't you [ __ ] hurt that
baby
so i just i missed that um i like ming
nan as fennek is a [ __ ] badass like
i'll watch her kick ass and look mean
all day long
um
she's great you know and it again like
they [ __ ] they know how to make [ __ ]
look great
the show looks amazing you know dave
kalani's shooting the [ __ ] out of it
that the volume continues to astonish
you know it seems like ilm knows how to
make a special effect or two
like it's it's it's top of the line
across the board these for most of these
first two episodes though they've been
outside like yeah
i mean it's they're in the desert you
can't [ __ ] volume that [ __ ] so that's
i know that's and that's a pain in the
ass so you can't control yeah the sun um
and lighting and stuff it's just
everything is [ __ ] lit although there
is a there's a handful of more than a
handful especially the first episode of
night scenes in the desert
and like that i think you can do in the
volume oh those are definitely indoors
you could get you get the the
distinct impression the night scenes are
indoors
yeah in a like not in a way where i'm
like i'm disappointed in a very star
warsing kind of way
yeah so i'm just i'm waiting i'm i'm
wait i might
the jury is out
what about
what about the ranker fake out
does that mean nice does that mean we're
going to see a ranker by the end of the
season
you don't you know nobody sh you don't
introduce a even an empty unloaded gun
without somebody wanting to use it right
so you know it seems like also that
that cage feels big enough for not just
one but to us
ant-man uh you're
big star wars kid uh i always fancy
myself a big star wars fan but you uh
take the cake from me
what was your take on boba one and two
um
boba won to me
uh felt very much like a pilot episode
instead of like what i felt like it
should have felt like which is like
episode 17 of
the disney plus star wars shows you know
like if you go back and re-watch like
the pilot episode of seinfeld or friends
or anything you're like oh how did i
ever start watching this this is not
this is not what the show should be
um i felt like it was a little
disjointed i'm kind of the opposite of
mark wherein like i did read this story
where boba
escapes the sarlacc pit which was like
an old i think it was called like
tales from jabba's palace or tales from
the tales of the bounty hunters they
came out like 20 years ago and it was
like a 40 page story and the entire
story was him trying to escape the
sarlacc and it was fantastic and amazing
and in this i was like oh
oh my the 40-page short story i wrote is
is 90 seconds on screen
you know i that was a little i would
have liked to see like the whole first
episode be like how hard it was to get
out of the sarlacc
um rather than like oh you throw this
thing you climb out and then you get
saved by tuscan raiders
um so i think i was a little
disappointed in that
and a little
very disappointed in the fact that like
we saw boba take out an entire squad of
stormtroopers
in
mando season two
and then he got like beat up by a bunch
of like the no-name batman 66 thugs on
the street of moses
what happened man you just killed a
whole bunch of stormtroopers and these
three dudes take you out and fenix gotta
chase them over the roofs what's going
on here let me let me tell you something
i believe with that comment you went
from banff man to bam [ __ ]
well done
uh yeah i did notice the weird like
de-powering of boba fett
that seems unexplained because he didn't
have a back de tank before he had his
armor back before he had jabba's palace
and he was
kicking [ __ ] ass and taking names
um and now yeah he gets rolled walking
down the street
but uh i think episode two
really
like i liked episode two twice as much
as i liked episode
one
and i
have heard some whispers of where
they're going and i think it will
continue to move in that direction
let's conjecture do you think the tuscan
raider kid makes it to the end
no
you think maybe that's your baby yoda
maybe that's the the straw that breaks
the the boba's back
is the like you killed that kid you did
what that'd be let me tell you something
if that's what happens and he just like
loses it and goes [ __ ] like
total rogue again
but it feels like
i don't know it's too early to say it
feels like but
it could be a case of uh you know
uh venom or
or
you know where you got somebody who's
uh an anti-hero or you're trying to
change you know a
a fan favorite into an anti-hero so you
could keep that
character you know
going make that character more vital um
harley quinn went from a sidekick to
one of the most important characters in
the dc universe
um and it feels like you know they're
like look we want this boba fett to be
around for a long time but
can't do it as a guy who just kills
everybody and stuff he's got to be a
more complicated tony soprano type
anti-hero anyone else get that vibe
yeah i mean it and maybe the tuscan
raider stuff will explain
his his sort of shift in ethos
of like he was just the dude who would
you know kill when somebody paid him to
do it and he had no moral compass or
center that wasn't financially motivated
and then he meets mando and meets the
child and then like has some sort of
awakening but that doesn't quite equate
to i want to rule with respect not with
fear like well fear is really good
though
yeah fear gets the job done
um so yeah just wondering the the
evolution of boba since the mando
um appearances is is is odd to me and so
hopefully they use some of that
flashback stuff to explain it
i feel like um personally as somebody
who's been watching these things since
the first one came out
um this is the most excited i've been
about star wars since i was a kid
and i enjoyed like uh you know
force awakens and and you know the
sequel trilogy and stuff but i eagerly
look forward to watching
this show every week uh i i like what i
i love what they're doing with star wars
over there
it gives me a chance to fan out you know
i i i breathed verified here and i got
very lucky because i was a fan who got
to make some [ __ ]
so
you know once you've seen behind the
curtain once you
see how the sausage is made maybe
[ __ ] ain't as magical for you any
anymore that's why i embrace those
[ __ ] marvel movies because those
marvel movies they make me feel like
what every
person who hates me on the internet or
every cr film critic would like me to
feel like
just a fan not a filmmaker
i watch those movies and instantly i'm
i'm back in the audience and there's no
desire to be doing what they do
it's it's what's making me happy just
like [ __ ] star wars made me happy
when i was a kid and [ __ ] like that so
i love
what they're doing man um you know we
can sit here and pick and be like well
they should or they could or why didn't
they
but this is the most excited i've been
for star wars like in a while and
and and i'm
genuinely
in love with how they're doing it i have
no and this is the other thing this is
how i know like i dig it i have no
interest no interest whatsoever
in like
oh i wanna i wanna do one of those i
wanna be involved like
i love just consuming this [ __ ]
like it was really i'll tell you
i should know better
but it was [ __ ] it was really fun to
not know how the banthas were moving and
to literally have to ask dave klein to
be like how'd that [ __ ] work you know
like
i should know how that works
but
anything that allows me to recapture
what brought me to the table in the
first place
the magic of star wars and stuff like
that started a lifelong romance with the
unreal with movies with make-believe
with sci-fi and fantasy and it
paved the way for the rest of my life
man i like make my living off of
goofy ass things that aren't true
and star wars will always be at the root
of it man not just being referenced in
my flicks but
as something that made me want to play
like first with action figures and then
later on on my own sets but this star
wars makes me want to sit and watch and
i'm so happy for that it doesn't create
in me any sort of like sometimes i'll
watch a thing and be like well i gotta
go to work on my [ __ ] because [ __ ] it
and i feel competitive i watch this i
don't feel competitive at all i'm like
more you're so good john favreau give me
more more so
i'm in
um this would be hard to they'd have to
make some real dog [ __ ] to lose me
yeah i mean the thing of it is like for
all of my nitpicking i know that if
if the mandalorian has taught me
anything
is that by episode four it'll be amazing
you know and it will it'll hit its
stride all of these things will pay off
and however they see them paying off and
you'll get some finale that that you
know both breaks your heart and spins
you forward into new story that's what
season one of mando did and i similarly
had issues with the first two or three
of mando
um i now know this is their pattern and
so i can still have you know thoughts
and and and feelings about how it
executes
while also still knowing full well that
by the time it kicks into gear that i
will find
i don't even need to find a way to love
it they will make me love it
and so
both things can be true at the same time
everybody
um
do you think you know dave filoni with
clone wars did a a great job of um
making episode 2 and episode 3 better if
you watch the entire clone wars series
the two
live-action movies get
better
is this
after watching this tuscan raider
episode do you think
if you go back and you re-watch episode
2
where anakin skywalker slaughters
women and children tuscan raiders
that you will now
buy into his transition to darth vader
more
than you did
in
2019 years ago when that movie came out
no but they better reference it now that
you said it now i'm like oh [ __ ] that's
right man like maybe that'd be awesome
if there was a scene where like they're
doing that telling of the story because
they'd use kind of sign language right
like there's a version of sign language
that the tuscan raiders use
um i think i read a story about it but
it'd be awesome if they told the story
about the [ __ ] time that this
crazy [ __ ] white boy came in and just
pulled the [ __ ] out of everybody
even for no reason yeah like we didn't
know what happened this guy just came in
swamp swamp swamp it's a little bit like
i am legend right
like in the comic book of i am legend
the zombies
like will smith is the legend he's like
their boogie man it's like anakin is the
tuskins boogie man
but they're saying in chat that the
people who are far more observant than
than us
that is a different uh tuscan tribe
uh especially in look we could tell by
the look in the mandel in uh boba fett
they're dressed completely different
than those tuscan raiders and stuff we
get that but
you know it doesn't mean there couldn't
have word has
come on kids these [ __ ] kids on the
internet who are like can't happen
because it's this and it's like can't we
just this ain't even real can't we just
make pretend
i'll just justify it they talk about the
jungle and waste your your your
tribe has been in the jungle and waste
for centuries
now we know that
the other tuscans in
coming going from
the lars homestead were from the jungle
and waste also so maybe it's two tribes
but they occupy the same plot of land
you know in the in the same desert on
the same planet i'm sure
you know uh
joe bob tuscan raider comes across
sam tuscan raiders like watch out for
the white guy on the speeder bike you
know yeah did this ever hey did this
ever happen to you
and then tell a horrific story about how
a kid showed up on a bike killed
everybody and [ __ ] off because he was
feeling poorly about himself um i i hope
i hope it's reference if it's not that's
fine but like when i when you know when
you said it suddenly i was like oh yeah
man
perfect opportunity to reference that
part of the lore and stuff yeah that's
when jedi came and killed my cousin yeah
or that news would spread would they
know that that grew guy grew up to be
darth vader
or would oh wouldn't that be the one to
tell him he'd be like i work with that
man his name was darth vader
that's my bad version of his kiwi accent
is he from his thank you is he from uh
new zealand is that what that is he is
yeah
and that is aquaman's dad correct
it very much is
first episode the whole time i was just
like when he takes off his helmet it's
aquaman's dad and he's just waiting for
nicole kidman to come back
i thought you could quell your phone
that's what's gonna happen episode seven
cole kim is gonna come out of the ocean
and he's gonna be like goodbye he's
gonna [ __ ] off
it turns out i do love lucy and then off
she goes a lot of people are griping
about wood like how are they how are
they burning fires in a on a desert
planet but they also in a line of
dialogue in this talk about when the
oceans disappeared
which explains all of that
i love that i've never heard that before
in star wars i was like holy [ __ ] they
used to have water on tatooine like that
is that correct me if i'm wrong that's a
new notion right i think so
i mean it's the first time he's been
canonized
in his vision didn't he see like water
or the ocean or something like that yeah
like the the waste the jonathan wastes
were waves
uh the dune c which made me very [ __ ]
hard
[Music]
heard that before they said the thing
that was like the thing
my penis is so easily pleased
when it comes to this [ __ ] it really is
i mean this guy this this guy cracked
the code as far as i'm concerned
i don't give a [ __ ] if people are like
he's just playing with action figures
i'm like good i like the way he does it
i like the way avro and filoni [ __ ] man
but this is favro just on this one right
i mean i think filoni is is
in the involved but fabs is writing the
scripts i've seen he wrote the first two
scripts by himself
yeah
um yeah man i'm in that's that's the
other thing it's like when i watch
everything i've watched them do now in
star wars and this is includes jj as
well
never once have i ever been like
oh i would have or could have or i
thought of that like each time
i'm like man i would never [ __ ] think
of that like what a good idea and yes i
mean i hadn't thought while watching it
that it is lawrence of arabia and it is
dance of the wolves but i'm like
steal from the best i hadn't [ __ ]
thought of that i was a cool [ __ ]
cool idea that made characters that you
know i've been around since i was a kid
one of the first star wars action
figures i ever had was the plastic
[ __ ] caped tuscan raider and suddenly
they made them viable and relevant where
i'm like give these [ __ ] a whole
series man
oh we saw nice too
yeah what why what was with this that i
was talking about
it's the same spice that like han solo
dumped back in the day is that spicy
spice mines yeah
of castle
yeah you got to see it open and go up
into the air and stuff like that's the
first time we've seen it physically
and that's
goes way back to one of the first lines
of dialogue in star wars
wow
i mean they're doing they're doing the
lord's work over there man
um happy with it can't wait to see where
it goes my only complaint
man [ __ ] this weekly [ __ ]
just
but you know like
it gives you something to look forward
to and my wife is actually like when's
that on again she asked me the other day
she's like when's new boba fett on him
like
it gives us stuff to talk about for
seven weeks
yeah
disney's very good to us disney is very
very good to us this show god no matter
what they do we should just be like
the only thing we have to talk about
um yeah man all right so that covers
boba for a red hot minute
what do we have after boba's done
uh what's next on there andor
obi-wan are both 2022.
boba or mando season three
is
probably end of 2022 and then ahsoka
that's what dave was shooting when he
left us dave is going back to work like
literally in the other room
on season three of mando so yeah that'll
be coming fairly soon too and ahsoka
when do they start
uh i think they start as soon as boba
wraps filming
wait so boba's still filming i'm sorry
not boba man
too many o's too many o's and a's
um yeah
so when like because this is gonna wrap
seven episodes
um so by what
end of february we'll be done with boba
is coming out this year too
yeah so we get like
ms marvel and andor and
kenobi
and
willow i guess
the guardians holiday special whenever
that's showing up
uh this from chat dark knight 0627
this is just interesting little factoid
more like this man the galaxy doesn't
find out that anakin was vader until the
leia novel bloodlines which was 11 years
after the battle of en endor
way after mando
and book of boba fett
so no the whole world don't know that
the whole galaxy doesn't know that
anakin skywalker and darth vader were
the same person that's interesting
mm-hmm
well
i think that's the kind of factoid
that'll get you [ __ ] laid
i bet you i mean ahsoka doesn't know
in
clone wars in rebels ahsoka doesn't know
she's starting to figure it out
remember when she fights him in [ __ ]
uh which one was that
rebels
oh grass
where he's like ahsoka
and she's like anakin uh still gives me
chills
we might see that
like a live-action version of that is
that possible
in flashback i mean if they've got
hayden christensen back for obi-wan why
would you not at least give a taste
really do like a live-action version of
one of the greatest [ __ ] star wars
scenes of all time that has never been
in a live action version of star wars
but isn't he also like he's he's he's
i thought that it was announced that he
was also in ahsoka
and that he was going to do both like
i thought it was
then the likelihood is increasing
indeed that he was going to be vader
in ahsoka and probably a force ghost
potentially in
in kenobi
um i don't know what's next
i don't know what's next on disney plus
but it's peacemaker starting soon on hbo
max the 15th i think that [ __ ] looks
great
live every trailer i've seen i'm like oh
my god i'm so [ __ ] there
um it looks enjoyable as hell man i
can't wait to watch that
and then what what what's the next
marvel movie
um i think it's doctor strange and
that's what may
i think it's may
and then i think um ant-man quantomania
is this year and then love and thunder
is this year also we're getting three
[ __ ] marvel movies this year
yeah
yeah there's [ __ ] three good reasons
to stay the [ __ ] above the ground man
god damn it what about the tv shows
isn't she hulk this no moon night isn't
moon night happening soon
she-hulk moon knight and miss marvel are
all probably happening in in 2022
um and then secret invasion
is tba
what if season two is tba as well or tbd
i know a lot
i know we have so much to
complain about and [ __ ] if you ever
go to twitter it's just the complaint
department and [ __ ] but like we do live
in a timeline where like we're getting
three marvel movies this year and i'm
sure you could be like look there's a
timeline where we get 12 and i'm like
all right well take me to that best of
possible world but
for right now
you know there are good things too
all bad
omicron is bad but [ __ ]
marvel's still doing good also getting
the batman this year
uh
this website says wakanda forever
is that coming out this year or was that
pushed
um i thought it was pushed to 2023 but i
don't know
flash movie comes out this year as well
jesus man like
this is a there's a lot of
they're trying i think what
feels like for 30 years people been
trying to get me
out of the director's chair like you
suck stop making movies i think they
figured out how to do it
just like a bunch of good [ __ ] that you
want to see man
tell you the one movie i look most
forward to this year
clerks three yeah baby
and i've seen it
it was good guys in it [ __ ]
if if he plays his [ __ ] cards right
this guy's in it
um
oh that's gonna be a magical movie but
that's months and months away
um i uh honestly probably look forward
more to doctor strange
just because i love that that wanda
story oh my god i can't wait to see
elizabeth
uh
get grief stricken again
i can't wait to see her wandered uh
wanda it up
i feel like maybe next episode um will
be a look look back look ahead
episode where you know we'll do the top
tens and then we'll do the [ __ ] we're
most excited for a sort of calendar
rundown of the [ __ ] coming down the pike
in 2022 that's a good idea unbox cylon
98 said sandman season one that's
[ __ ] this year
this could be the greatest year of our
lives
i say that as a man with an adult child
we need like
we need like another we need just like a
holiday for the year where it's like
there's so much great stuff coming out
everybody take the year off
yeah
people are yelling at me in chat
raymie's strange we started by talking
about that we start by saying that's in
the future black adam they're pointing
out
did you hear they're in talks with seth
rogen to play ben grimm somebody said in
chat i didn't hear that is that true i
didn't hear that either wow man
oh spider verse 2 is also yes and that
trailer looks fine and spider verse two
is part one of two
so it's not even like oh man we're gonna
get that amazing movie and then be like
when's the next one they're like the
next one comes out like when the sequel
comes out pretty damn soon
oh yeah what a great year man
matt
is probably coming out
grendel is coming to netflix it will
indeed in some fashion or another
boys season three
now we're just reading [ __ ] off the
internet but i mean these are all the
things sometimes you need this man
particularly like you know as people are
as the [ __ ] coveted numbers are
rising again looking for a little
sunshine holy [ __ ]
like let's just make it through this
crime nonsense man
you know i
do what you want but like
knowing that all this was ahead of me
i'll take as many vaccinations as they
[ __ ] give me man cause i want to see
all this [ __ ]
god damn this [ __ ] looks good man
umbrella academy season three
oh we didn't even watch copacay at
kobakai
what season four or three
four four
four just dropped fairly recently so
hopefully by the next time
uh we get together again
i will have
binged uh
cobra kai season four because i have
loved
seasons one two and and three um so i
look forward to maybe we'll talk about
that next week if i get to
to do them off i i don't know if i can
bring my wife into that show four
seasons in it feels like a kind of thing
you would have to
start from the jump or at least i'd want
to start her from the jump number one
she's my wife i like jumping her number
two i'd wanna bring her to the beginning
of that amazing show
to see
like how it was built like i i remember
falling down the rabbit hole and being
like oh my god
like they found a way to make a [ __ ]
show about the karate kid that i can't
not watch
some gifted storytellers out there doing
some cool things and they're all coming
in 2022. so yeah yeah yeah
all right what about that elvis movie
too isn't that intimidating
elvis picture
oh my god did i you know how many movies
elvis made in his life tummy i forgot
already but there were a lot
closer to the trip i remembered
everything but now it's starting to slip
away
but i'll remember when i see that
[ __ ] new movie with
baz lorman and [ __ ] um all right
uh this is a part of the show kids where
we
uh answer questions answer questions uh
we uh we do a little q a
people seem to enjoy this part of the
show when we do it live
it's fun people win [ __ ]
do it hear streaming
you just win the the honor of a good
question
it's true
it's true you don't get a prize but you
do get the satisfaction knowing you made
the show better uh the
questions aren't picked by me or mark
man uh we leave it in the hands
of banff man himself or should i say
banff [ __ ]
uh so banff man uh tell us
what would uh the the folks the good
audience the good folks who watch fat
man beyond like to know this week all
right uh we've probably done this one
before in the past but
you know with the release of book of
boba fett i think we can revisit
uh die avalon wants
us to answer if dave filoni approached
you to create a new
eight episode star wars themed disney
plush show
which story do you pick what character
what story
it'd be tough because honestly i think i
would say no because like i like this
[ __ ] too much and like it's
like i know what people get paid to make
things so i know like you know if i did
a show like that it wouldn't be for free
and i could make a chunk of change
and this is gonna sound like [ __ ]
but like i can make a similar chunk of
change
doing other things
and it'd be more important to me to
maintain
like
that things role in my life as an
entertainment that fuels me
rather than an entertainment that i need
to then create and it's not purely
altruistic i'll be honest with you who
the [ __ ] wants to deal
with
the pressure
like you know
maybe if you'd asked me
prior to masters the universe and stuff
but like
i've been at the receiving end of people
who are not happy when you don't play
with their toys the way you want
they want them to be played with
so i
you know
i've loved star wars my whole life
i love this current incarnation of star
wars it makes me so happy
i i don't want to risk losing that it
wouldn't be worth the money wouldn't be
worth the high profile gig of people
being like finally he gets to make a
star wars and [ __ ]
like
is
you know
george lucas
created all this stuff and he made some
movies and years went by and he's like
you know what
like i think i'm gonna go back i think
it'd be so much fun
to play with my toys again
and
like people made george lucas feel so
bad
about you know what he did with star
wars that he sold it
to disney he was just like i don't do
this anymore i saw an article somewhere
where he was like it's like it's not
he didn't say this was the reason but he
talked about the feedback and he was
like
wasn't like worth
like that kind of heartbreak and stuff
so in you know i'm not saying poor
little rich man like or feel bad for the
rich guy but
star wars was his heart
and you know and then it became hugely
commercial and stuff and then he tried
to get back to his heart and then a
bunch of people were like jar jar you're
a [ __ ] idiot and then he was like
what's the point and he just kind of
like
got rid of it and you know now it's in
the hands of people who are doing and
they're bringing him in sounds like and
everything's being done the way george
would have or or you know
there's a huge consideration for george
i i don't know it's just
to me it wouldn't be i know this is a
fantasy game so we'll eventually play
the fantasy version
but it just it wouldn't be worth it to
me like it's more valuable to me as
something that i could look forward to
from the outside
you know it's nice to have a little
mystery in my life where i'm like i
don't know [ __ ] like i know dave
kline he don't tell me [ __ ] about that
[ __ ] show he terrified of getting
fired so
like it's something that i don't have
you know access to or hear about it's
just something i get to enjoy like every
other [ __ ] normal ass person in the
world man no privilege here whatsoever
i'm sitting in seats just like everybody
else and
that's valuable to me there aren't many
things that make me feel that way marvel
and and star wars both [ __ ] disney
locked them both up man the mouse has my
[ __ ] dick and heart
um they have they have that power for me
so like i don't
i'm happy to make kevin smith [ __ ] that
being said
in this fantasy world
where like every other talented
filmmaker is [ __ ] dead and they're
like
it's up to you it's like [ __ ]
battlestar galactica
they've gone through the entire gga
roster
and the luggage you and yui bowl so
here we are
uh what would you do um let me see
what would i want to do
i don't know i mean now i would be
inspired by what they do because like my
answers in the beginning probably would
have been
very basic but now i'm like look at the
possibilities look at the like the deep
dive you could do on
on characters i guess the point of this
is i'm not even [ __ ] imaginative
enough
to give you a response to the question
in this q a let alone be handled the
[ __ ] reigns of a show and that's what
i think about when i watch that show
each and every episode i know some
people in chat have broken it down to be
like come on man mandalorian he goes to
a town he fights a monster he goes the
next time fights another mine how hard
is that
i i watch these shows and i would never
think to do anything that they do never
once have i seen something where i'm
like yeah i saw that coming and it just
makes me happy so i proved positive that
i couldn't do it is i can't even [ __ ]
think of a show that i would like to do
i'm sure if i look at chat
a bunch of people have suggestions for
me and they're like oh yeah you could do
this you could do this i assure you
whatever it would have been it would
have been a chatty [ __ ] thing
uh no action whatsoever
if there was some it would have been a
lot like that scene in mandalorian you
saw my star wars that scene in
mandalorian was the two dudes and the
storm troopers or talking to each other
and punching baby yoda in the bag
pretty much what i would have done
what are you what if you did star wars
what if though
because that runs adjacent so if
anybody's like i don't like what you did
to lando you'd be like it's what if man
you could play
it's like that's like the
you're almost you almost can play
you almost had me
but the problem is there will still be
a reaction to me playing with toys that
are not mine look i can do anything the
[ __ ] i want with jay and silent bob
guilt-free with dante randall and if
anyone goes hey you did it wrong i'm
like you are out of your [ __ ] skull
it's whatever i do as long as i walk
this earth for my characters is [ __ ]
canon for heaven's sakes so like you
know
that goes without saying from my work
for me to as i've learned for me to go
into somebody else's room and be like oh
these are fun this is how i would do it
you you're gonna have a host of [ __ ]
opinions and my the difference is
someone could have an opinion about what
i do with my characters i don't give a
[ __ ] that's my world
someone has an opinion about what i did
with characters that were not mine that
i'm playing with
i can't help but give a [ __ ] about i
know i'm not equipped to work on
somebody else's [ __ ] based on what i
went through with masters of the
universe like everyone else in the
business was like what do you give a
[ __ ] a bunch of people on the internet
like don't don't like i'm like you don't
get it like that's
that's where i live that's my world like
i
you know that means something to me and
so the idea of possibly
losing that with something that i'd love
dearly like [ __ ] star wars or marvel
not necessary whatsoever
um over to you mark um i think for for
me the key
is finding a pocket of that universe
that you can play in where there's some
latitude
that's a character whose name every star
wars fan knows but has a not a ton of
information about
um and yes this guy has been in some
novels and he's made it onto onto
a few iterations of cartoons
but i think there is there is a story to
be told that is star wars antilles
i think i think the wedge antilles story
gives you a lot of juice i think he
survives
all of the luke skywalker stuff i think
he was an escaped you know imperial
fighter pilot
who defected from the imperial navy and
then brought all that knowledge with him
to to the to the rebel alliance is that
true yeah he was one of the founders of
rogue squadron with luke skywalker he
led the assault on on death star 2 as
the the leader of the new red squadron
yes did you get that uh that that
[ __ ] former imperial ship
that checks out doesn't it batman
i
don't know i know wedge is like way way
backstory which was what i wanted to do
but
i'll internet it wedges way way back
story yeah what is that was
i believe and i could be wrong but i
think i'm right that his parents owned a
gas station
like a where starships filled up
and they were killed by
imperials of some sort and that then he
went out and i wanted to do
like wings like the show wings but it
was like the antilles parents gas
station and the little boy grows up to
be wedge
um
yeah i i according to wikipedia and you
know whatever it's worth
it says before defecting to the rebel
alliance antilles was an imperial cadet
call signed thai ss 25 of the sky strike
academy
before defecting and founding rogue
squadron with lake skywalker
um
so wait so when is that when did they do
that
um i think that's been in some books and
stuff like that but that was that was
pre that would have been between
um
you know
um
[ __ ] i guess but
it's it's pre-rogue one in the timeline
and all before force awakens
yeah yeah i mean it's before new hope
yeah it would have been right around a
new hope time
no no as released to the world the
notion of a storm trooper
flipping sides
in to me
was introduced in
force awakens but what i'm hearing here
is this happened in the lore
like in some fan fiction or some
extended universe fiction long it was in
star wars rebels uh season three episode
four the antilles extraction um in 2016
is where that was established
and that is that before
force awakens
yeah that's
that's a couple years before a new hope
no you're missing everybody release
order
i'm talking about oh in release order
in release order who had the idea first
is what i'm saying i thought jj was the
guy who had the idea to be like oh
stormtrooper who flip side force awakens
is 2015.
and so star wars in the world of star
wars jc or in the cartoons was there
ever a stormtrooper that went good
no well but wedge wasn't a stormtrooper
he was a pilot that went
good which
in in
other backstories of han solo han solo
had done the same thing
um and i know like biggs went to the
imperial academy and flip sides but i
don't know if there's a storm trooper
like the grunt
the infantryman that had done it
in chat they're saying filoni had the
idea first so it must have been
yeah i mean release order is force
awakens than that episode of rebels but
who knows how long that those things had
been
served in concert with each other
um
so yeah but i just i think that's an
interesting trajectory i think
you know basically it's an air force
show
you know it's about you know a guy who
leaves the bad guys and joins the good
guys brings all the skill with him
and then sort of lives in the shadow and
finds a way to thrive in the shadow of
luke skywalker who shows up out of
nowhere as the hero of the rebel
alliance and whether there's competition
whether there's resentment whether
there's
eventual sort of coming to terms with it
and then friendship and then
you know what happens to my friend at
the end like now he's a [ __ ] jedi
like he's never get behind the the the
wheels of a of an x-wing anymore he's
not a fighter pilot anymore he's a
goddamn cult hero
you know how i carry on the mantle of
what luke started and how i just keep on
flying i just got to stay in the air
like or stay in the skies whatever that
is like i think i think there's a show
there and i think it's also a dude who
has a very unique perspective
but a different perspective on all of
the giant events
of the the prime trilogy
is kind of
fascinating he's kind of like the
hawkeye right like if luke and these
wizards are
just a guy who's like i just i i just
have a spaceship and i shoot things
i just drive this car
um
here in chat john riegelman saying way
before filoni it was in the books so it
was a lot of the stuff you could trace
back to the extended universe books yeah
i know chuck wendig
um
wendy put him in one aftermath he's in
that book
he i mean in the old
canon books he becomes a like a senator
in the new republic
um as per usual uh chat came up with a
number of suggestions for star wars that
i could do where i was like oh yeah i
could do that uh somebody was like why
not do a cheers set at mos at the
cantina i was like oh yeah that would
make sense i could do that
this way i can do star wars and not
[ __ ] break anything uh somebody else
said tag and [ __ ] which is uh
the wonderful
rubio book about like essentially it's
uh
rosencrantz and guildenstern but like
these two [ __ ] knuckleheads who wind
up at every important moment of star
wars history i i would absolutely do
that and there you go i wouldn't be
creating it i'd be basing it on what
kevin rubio did so in that instance i
could get my head around it it's already
been preconceived for me all i have to
do is shoot it although as we heard from
dave today
every episode is preconceived i found
that fascinating he was just like the
entire thing is pre-vised out
um in order for them to like light the
volume and [ __ ] like
that's crazy that's seeing the movie
before the movie is
even seen yeah i mean it's probably more
akin to animation than it is live action
because
there it is we saw it all before we
render it with actual people
um all right did you even answer i did i
said wedge wedge that's right that's a
and also but you did say wedge antilles
um is his last name antilles
yeah what's the name of the guy who was
owned who owned the droids uh antarctica
somebody with the last name smith
you come across a few smiths
yeah antilles is like the smith of star
wars smith of star wars
there's my project the smith of star
wars
it's about how all these antilles about
a guy named antilles everyone's like oh
[ __ ] you're the one that [ __ ] you
know helped luke skywalker he's like no
man i just got his last name or if the
dude whose name is luke skywalker
who's not actually lipscomb he's like
but i'm listen i just i run this [ __ ]
gas station
basically i just want to make the big
lebowski in the star wars universe which
seems like that's what they're up for
maybe that's how i do it maybe that's my
way in you know how like they're like
well episode two of boba fett is
uh you know lawrence of arabia and star
wars is is uh
um karassawa uh influence and stuff how
they're always pulling from classic
cinema or or you know older cinema
i could just pull from [ __ ] clarks
not even the cantina man it's just like
a bodega
in
moscow you know we're [ __ ] there's a
human guy and one guy who's i don't know
[ __ ] you tell me jahwah i don't give
a [ __ ] we'll figure it out
and they're you know people come in
people come out
all the [ __ ] of star wars happens right
outside the door
and they talk about it they're like oh
[ __ ] look at that ig unit with a little
weird green guy on his back he's
shooting all his stormtroopers
it's [ __ ] up right yeah but they don't
[ __ ] walk 10 feet to go engage we're
gonna go outside why would i go outside
the [ __ ] am i gonna do out there
um all right that's a great question man
that would have been [ __ ] at the bar
kevin rubio texted me he says let kevin
know that i give him permission to do
the tag and [ __ ] show
oh so you've got an endorsement
me and rubio the two kevs we're the only
we're gonna make that happen at disney
plus we're gonna go into favre and
felony and be like tag and bank and
they're gonna be like there's the door
i bet you that i bet you both of those
dudes know that book and really love
that book though
i think it can't not
you can't not love tag and bing you
can't love star wars and not enjoy that
book it was such a clever concept
i you know what i bet if the guardians
of the galaxy christmas special does
well
that that wouldn't be off the table like
something that's kind of like canon
adjacent it's like silly and fun
you know
do it all on the volume for cheap
pete
den cat said but isn't jay and salam bob
a tribute to uh c-3po and r2 d2 um
that's what i was told by a a very smart
film journalist when i was showing
clerks back in 1994 and i was like oh
i hadn't thought of that yes it's
exactly what they are that's what they
became
they certainly weren't in clerks but
they became that throughout the rest of
the movies uh anthony perrone in chat
said
jeff's antilles kiss
sweet
um all right where are we going next all
right uh
junice
mwasio
uh says i'm a huge fan from finland
um boba fett was resurrected by favreau
in a big bad way
his question
which dead fictional movie character
would you bring back from the dead to
wreak havoc so it wouldn't not
necessarily star wars but some
somebody who's died that you'd want to
reinvent can i pitch you this excellent
idea that i've always had that i wanted
to see and just make so much [ __ ]
money if you did it do it you make a
spider-man movie and you bring back the
green goblin you bring back you bring
back every villain that he ever fought
and killed man who wouldn't see that
movie never happened
don't [ __ ] on my dreams mark
it's too hard
um what character that's dead darth
vader
we didn't get enough of him man like you
know now they did one of the coolest
things they ever did with that character
after he died in rogue one i want more
of that i want to see that guy slicing
and dicing
um who else would i like back
i mean it's too late now because he's
all older but jack nicholson's joker i
thought it was a real dumb move to
[ __ ] kill off the joker but that's
set the tone for all those movies where
they started like killing his arch
villains at the end and it's like have
you guys ever heard the comics like
he puts them in a place they get out you
know rinse repeat we do it again
um let's see who else has died that i
would bring back
i don't know over to you mark well i
think it's
um the one that popped into my head
because it's
it is hard because in most of the things
that we like they don't actually kill
people
you know they're they're often you know
cast out put in prison or whatever but
comic book literature science fiction
literature nobody's ever really dead
but
um i would love to see
a a a
calm story where khan is brought back
from the dead in star trek
khan i think the kong i'm like dude we
just had a [ __ ] thing that's a kong
[ __ ] come on yeah bring combat from the
dead yes but like not benedict
cumber-con
but an actual like real con
um
and also i think i think there's a there
could be a scary story in jack torrance
who it turns out did not die in a garden
you know that he uh that he got
resuscitated that he whatever the [ __ ]
it was he's evil and their supernatural
[ __ ] afoot
like maybe he just didn't die in a in a
hedge maze and so what happens to young
danny torrance when his father shows up
again very very angry at him
it'd be cool if they brought back
michael myers
hmm
i haven't seen him in a movie in a while
i don't mean the [ __ ] halloween guy
what about uh the flying graysons come
back to life
but they're like evil like the royal
flush gang and nightwing has to go out
and figure out who this gang is that's
terrorizing
the city
and through the course of eight episodes
you know towards the end he discovers
it's his
his family who he thought was gone who
set him on the path
to become nightwing
and then he has to deal with oh my god
my
arch enemy is my
mom and dad
i'm i was just about to look for money
to throw at you i would buy your comic
book sir
i'm interested in that
so bad
um
in chat some folks are saying michael
bookman said the vega brothers
tarantino verse
um
jeff key in the chat said that jack
torrance died in the boiler room
um in the novel in the book yeah
but you know
i like the idea that
i mean you get to do
[Music]
the the
the notion of continuing the shining
always intrigues me
they just did it recently and then they
didn't they would didn't they was
talking about doing one is that gone now
um the overlook as a as a tv show i
think it's i think it
it might be sort of in a limbo
where it's not entirely dead but also
not entirely alive
it's in development as hollywood likes
to say
um
unbox cyclone 98 says elvis yes
do it bring this man back so he can make
his 32nd film not counting the concert
movies he made 31 films mark i
remembered there it is in a relatively
short amount of time in a
crazy short amount of time thank you for
pointing that out
um all right man
oh trey watson has a good one leonardo
dicaprio's character in the departed i
hated that he [ __ ] died in that movie
like it really not pissed me off where i
was like [ __ ] you but like i just i was
really like no come on man this kid was
finally getting some [ __ ] together
things were gonna work out he got his
man
you know he's [ __ ] maybe going to
work things out veer pharmaka boom
oh
that was shocking to me and i've seen
[ __ ]
what was it um
uh not city on fire um
infernal affairs vernal affairs but
still man i was
anyway i agree with that bring that
[ __ ] back so i would have watched a
few more movies with him god the
departed is a fun movie you just you
know what
i know what i'm doing tonight
also leonardo dicaprio's character from
titanic
[ __ ] rose there's plenty of room on
this door could you imagine the movie
begins with like it's like [ __ ] boba
fett he just out of the water
rose
rose bukater yeah
spent the rest of her life on the run
from jack dawson
oh [ __ ] they're like titanic
re-conceived as only guillermo del toro
speaking of which have you seen
his movie nightmare alley yeah
holy the [ __ ]
what's really good
it's insanely good and it's also one of
the darkest films i've ever watched and
when we were all done watching i was
like why did i like that so much and my
jennifer was like it's like a very
well-made version of tusk and i was like
you're right it's just like there it is
and dark and weird and [ __ ] not like
same thing but just
in the same realm of like this is
[ __ ]
like my my i loved it but my when it was
over i i turned to my wife i was like
who did he make that for
and she's like the same people you made
tusk for i was like you're absolutely
right like it's
it's so
dark
um and so specific
yet so insanely well made and
like in a in a better timeline
this would be a movie everyone has seen
and everyone is talking up as like a
possible best picture contender yeah i
mean they're going to make a big push
for it because it has all of those
things that voters love they got to push
hard though because ain't nobody [ __ ]
talking about this movie which is a damn
shame i mean also but i don't know who's
talking about any oscar movie at this
point because nobody's seen very much
i mean there's there's a lot of chatter
around don't look up of course
right and the way of the dog a lot of
way of the dog chatter have you seen the
the
tammy faye movie yet with jessica
chastain i have not i've not they'll
both probably get nominated andrew
garfield and her are wonderful in it and
stuff i am watching um
writers of justice have you seen this
movie
it's a norwegian movie um starring mads
mikkelsen
as
a soldier whose wife gets killed in a
train accident
and then he gets confronted by a couple
of like computer geeks
who've ground the numbers and figured
out statistically this could not have
been an accident
um
and that they they tell him ultimately
who's responsible for his wife's murder
and he goes on a revenge tear like he
literally just starts killing them it's
the weirdest batman movie you've ever
seen
um it's
but it's also incredibly sweet and deep
and it's about grief and loss and and
figuring out ways to move on and all
these people who are broken together but
form a family
in a quest for revenge it's
it's subtitled so you'll like it but um
is it a movie or a show it's a movie
it's a movie what's it called again
writers of justice and when did it come
out i came out earlier this year i want
to say like summer i'm [ __ ] in man
you just sold me a [ __ ] cool sounding
flight yeah it's on hulu now
that's where i can watch it riders of
justice yeah like and he's great because
it's [ __ ] mads mikkelsen um but it's
it's really really good i was surprised
at how much i'm liking it it's a reader
i'm in um the uh i've been loving yellow
jackets you watching yellow jackets um
i've watched the first two i'm behind
but it's really so strong it is there's
only two episodes left oh
i mean there's no way they don't go
again i it doesn't seem like they're
going to be able to
wrap everything up in [ __ ] two
episodes so it feels like they'll keep
going but really wonderful show
um
and uh all right so back to the
questions back to the question
our last question
last question um
b.o fisher was interested to know if you
had to make a superhero horror film
what characters do you use
and i think we take playdoh
josh alvarez in chat is saying are you
all watching station 11
it's basically the story of how comic
books help a little girl survive the
apocalypse
i've seen the first episode and it's
gorgeous it's beautiful
but be forewarned the apocalypse is a
viral pandemic
so it looks like are you kidding me yeah
like it's very close to the bone
um
but it's really good
um i'm in man
i'm in
uh okay back to the question um
uh bl fisher if you had to make a
superhero horror film
what characters would you use and i'm
gonna say take blade off because we've
kind of gotten that
so one more time if i was going to make
a supernatural superhero
horror film who do you what character do
you build the film around
and make it horror
um
um
i mean alan moore did such an amazing
job of of uh
with swamp thing
you know he took a character that was
kind of
one note
and gave him this deep mythology and
tied him into the supernatural
took the character into hell
to battle for the soul of his love still
one of the greatest [ __ ] single
issues of a comic book i ever read is
that swamp thing annual
um
you know i don't know i i mean i know
they've done swamp thing fairly recently
and a pretty good version of it from
what i understand
uh but
that would probably be the way in for me
because then you get to [ __ ] around with
anton arcane and the unmen and [ __ ] like
that
i think that's what i would
i would do
you know they've there have been a few
cinematic incarnations of swamp thing
and one was closer to the comics than
the other
one was closer to the more to alan
moore's comics than the other
um and then the series that they did
recently sounded like they got a lot
right too um but
i think there's like just a horror
version of that show like the the book
always made houma louisiana
seem like this haunted [ __ ] town i
think we're gonna get a taste of the
flavor of that in in the
the sandman show that's doing for
netflix but that's what i would do i
would do swamp thing the alan moore
swamp thing run it was so horror based
i remember one of like the
there's like uh this thing feeding on
like children's fear the
home for kids
um
and there was a kid who
it
the whatever the creature is the demon
is
it
launches it latches on to a child's
imagination and feeds on that
and so i'll never forget like there's a
passage talking about this kid who like
had only heard the word cancer and knew
that it had killed his mom or dad or
grandmother or grandfather
and so the the beast took the form of
like what the child imagined cancer was
like [ __ ] like that you can make
[ __ ] up horrifying [ __ ] visuals
with
um yeah if you want something spooky man
go read that alan moore swamp thing run
it's incredible that's what i would do
what about you mark um two characters
come to mind the first is is
you know the easy version which is
constantine
you know i think that that the canon
reeves sort of flickered with horror
like it never went like deep deep her
but it
off of swamp thing as well yeah you know
so i think there's you know a guy who
deals in magic and and demons and the
netherworlds and all that [ __ ] like
horror feels like very close to that so
you can it's an easy it's an easy nudge
into full-on horror
but the one that was a little more
interesting to me
is like
i i loved that there's a sequence in man
of steel
where
you first see clark struggling in school
because some of his x-ray vision gets
out of whack
and he just starts like seeing through
everything like
there's there's no longer a barrier
between his control and whatever and
suddenly he's seeing bones and
musculature and
veins and skin and through like all of
that stuff like powers when you're young
and don't know how to control them
feel
dangerous and scary
and then thinking about like professor x
like what happens if you're charles and
xavier and you're like 13 or 14 years
old and suddenly you can hear
everybody's thoughts
suddenly you can read mind some of you
can control minds
like what
what what roads do you go down
what what what darknesses do you first
bump up against before you decide to set
limits for yourself
you know what's what's the the deep dark
angry that he sees on other people in
the world that he doesn't know how to
protect himself from
yeah you know i think that that that
that kind of sort of cerebral heart that
mental horror that can then give way to
like body horror is all kind of like
juicy and it's it's less you know
scary demons but it's more
cronenberg in in a way that i think
could be really [ __ ] up did they ever
do him as a teenager in the comics
do you know they must have over the
years like somebody must have
did he have his mutant abilities as a
teenager because that would be kind of
interesting to be like that guy like
there are many mutants and they've shown
many mutant stories
of teenagers dealing with their mutant
abilities but
the most powerful mutants in the
universe
go i'm going through puberty
like yeah i'm not even joking it's like
the
think about like the journey that your
head and heart took when you were a
[ __ ] teenager figuring out
um
you know [ __ ] who you loved
um
if you could love them if they loved you
back all that [ __ ] teenage heartbreak
but then grafted on to
the most powerful [ __ ] psychic mind
the world has ever known if that
person's heart is broken is the whole
world's heart
broken because [ __ ] some girl won't
go to a dance with them or some guy yeah
you know and also the idea that like if
he falls asleep in dreams what is his
mind doing when he's asleep
you know who is it affecting what is
seeping into [ __ ]
oh my god that's so that's another
[ __ ] billion dollar i just shut the
[ __ ] up
just
strike that from the record god that's
[ __ ] good have they done that
if they have i don't know
i i don't know if they've done the
teenage charles xavier or just the idea
that like he goes to sleep and he's not
in [ __ ] control of his faculties what
happens
when that mind is unleashed when he's
not harnessing it because he can't not
[ __ ] sleep oh my god
i want that
that's the kind of [ __ ] i want right
there
that's the juice give me that juice nerd
large says so the new mutants yeah kind
of but still
yeah but different
i think the scary one the scariest
movies i don't do horror movies but one
of the scariest movies i ever saw
because i i went to the theater and i
saw it because i thought it was a sci-fi
movie is event horizon
oh [ __ ] and
what if
the fantastic four movie
was event horizon and they go off into
deep space
and they discover
mephisto the devil
on this spaceship and that's where they
get their powers
i'm all for it but tranq did the
you know science gone wrong cronenberg
event horizon version of fantastic four
kind of josh trank
in his version the body horror version
of it
it wasn't that scary though i felt more
like
i don't know i actually i you know a lot
of people [ __ ] on that movie but i i
thought
it had it had a tone to it
that was
didn't feel like a marvel movie
didn't feel like a dc
felt like its own thing like felt like
it really felt like a movie out of time
like a movie that
could have been embraced and existed
before comic book movies
were made
but before they became popularized like
if you had done that circa blade
i i think people would have taken it a
lot better
um but it's just you know that that
movie was made in a world where
everyone's like this is what a marvel
movie looks like and so right there
you've got an uphill battle there were
interesting ideas in it but the you know
the
the doctor doom stuff at the end kind of
yeah i mean it's it's a weird movie but
that pocket
in the middle when they come back with
their powers
like that body horror segment it's like
10 minutes long
where like mr fantastic reed wakes up
and his body is all over the room and
and johnny doesn't know how to stop the
fire and ben is just sitting in a room
by the in the dark because he's just
like he doesn't want to look at himself
like oh that is actually really
evocative and effective it's just a
bunch of the rest of the movie doesn't
work no
absolutely but interesting ideas um but
i'm saying i'm not saying like yeah
[ __ ] everyone go see it but i'm
saying like that they have approached
the idea of
you know
fantastic four through the horror prism
um
but man
is that it [ __ ] did we just run out
again well you told me to shut up so i
shut up no go keep talking
but now i realize the wisdom of you're
telling me to shut up um i i've got one
last question that's not really a q a
question but somebody was asking if uh
you guys are going to do commentaries
for the back half of motu
like didn't didn't you and josh roush do
those
yeah yes but the writers um
yeah
i mean i
you know
we did it the first time and i got
[ __ ] ratioed to [ __ ] on those videos
man like we were so fun to do
and informative and then
a lot of joy was stolen but you know
what i'm sure a lot of people who are
like well you stole my joy by not making
the masters universe show that i wanted
to see so
there's there i guess
yeah
i don't know i always think it's
interesting to hear that stuff though
right like
i was happy to share it until
until a bunch of people
came after me
and then i wasn't interested anymore
yeah but they did not come after you
because we did commentary videos that
was just a place for them to come up
that was a venue for it yeah
they were sitting right there man oh
there's you go back and you look at like
some of those
the videos from like that era from when
we drop and this is only going back to
like june july
like uh it's crazy the amount of like
comments and dislikes is
i'm a lover not a fighter
so you know i bet i get sometimes people
like don't get what i do at least with
my characters and [ __ ] i mean a lot of
people
don't like and i'm not saying they're
not smart enough they're just like it
ain't my [ __ ] thing
that's fine i've dealt with that forever
with my own [ __ ] but dealing with it
with somebody else's ip
as covered previously it's just
yikes
yep
so i guess that's a no
um yeah yeah i mean never say never you
know michael keaton's back is [ __ ]
bad
so 30 years from now
20 years from now we all sit down me
mark uh [ __ ] eric tim and dia and
finally record the writer's commentary
for the back half of the season
where dia is is like the one who gets up
and gets us all food because we're all
too old to do it
she was the youngest one she's the
youngest one
by the time we get around to it she'll
be old too
yeah but some of the longest one
that's true she'd be like spell getty
who was the youngest one in the golden
girls but played the oldest one
um
to bring it all back to betty white rest
of power
uh there it is kids we got no more show
we got no more questions right no more
answers
we got no more show we got nothing left
for you we emptied the tank it's been
three
solid [ __ ] hours man we started with
dave klein who for the last three hours
that we've been sitting here [ __ ]
blabbing our mouths off has been
literally making [ __ ] mando season
three
making a star war
can't wait to see it
um
we thank dave kline for taking time to
pop in we'll get them again
um we uh thank the good folks
at uh native
uh for uh sponsoring the second half of
the show and the [ __ ] my new friends
at emmy
for sponsoring earth avenue yeah some
ramen vegan ramen man
i'm all over that i got it coming
already
um we thank jc who just banffed out of
there to put up the emmy logo there he
is banff man
for uh bringing us all to you and making
this all possible we thank
the great nate gonzalez did you see this
week's artwork it was sweet
you got to be dengar i was happy about
it i would have preferred to be dengar
but i'm like a [ __ ] sometimes he puts
me in the
the you know like the batman robin roll
i become batman i don't always feel like
batman so i
i think i would have been a much better
dengar you're more the boba fett you're
the guy with the gaffy stick who's like
it sucks
how it could be better it's clobbering
time
i'm just a guy wrapped up a bandage just
like apparently i'm not very good at my
job
i keep getting [ __ ] up um
nate gonzalez does art you could go to
he's got a website what is it dark nate
returns dot com i think near like big
cartel dot dark nate returns or go to
dark knight returns on twitter i'm sure
you can find all of it uh and you can go
to a store and you can buy the artwork
and stuff
he's got a lot of it it's beautiful uh
we thank him for doing the artwork and
we thank uh the guy
right down there
down there
down there there it is
down there
um i feel like uh [ __ ] like one of
the brady kids like looking down
remember they looked from their boxes
down you know
oh it's with the meat we think uh uh the
guy without whom there is no [ __ ]
show the the only thinking man on the
show he sometimes thinks too much and
gives out billion dollar [ __ ] ideas
no i need to stop that oh my god think
before you speak man like i know like
we're all like trying to not to say the
wrong thing so as not to upset people
out there in the world and [ __ ] but it
upsets me when you give out brilliant
ideas
it is my gift
it really is i'm a river to my people
the uh you come here for the pop culture
kids you leave here with some cool ideas
for your own stories and [ __ ] don't
forget to tell them who inspired you man
mark bernardin that's it
uh for the very first episode of fat man
beyond man for 2022 welcome to 2022
ladies and gentlemen
um i'm kevin smith i am mark bernard
tune in next time kid same
fat time same
fat channel spodcast.com or
youtube.com slash kevin smith big 22
jeff's kiss
this is
greetings everybody and welcome to the
aka ask if anything every saga has a
10-year anniversary ladies and gentlemen
and this is what happens with jay and
sam bob get old i'm kevin smith